Eva Roots, ladies and gentlemen. Hello sir? A brother. What's going on?
Everything and nothing. Everything and nothing. Yeah. You tell me your,
this is a crazy time for you. You, your vagabond and you traveling around man.
The gypsy. I like the term no man. No bad's good. Vagabond makes.
Is that like I'm pulling, I gotta stick with it, but yeah,
those kind of Baghdad nomads. Like a gypsy with money. Yeah. No,
but Gypsies over, is that a derogatory term you didn't use to be,
I think it might be now they can say it like king of the Gypsies is Tyson fury.
He's allowed to say it. He's allowed to say it might be one of them things.
Yeah, we got wear it like that. A lot of people do. Those words are expanding.
There's more of those words than before. Can can say,
I'm gonna get in trouble right now. Can they just call themselves?
I don't know man. I don't know. That's a good one. That used to be a normal one.
You know, if you know what's really crazy,
if you look at when kids had were born with downs syndrome,
the original term was mongoloid idiot.
That used to be like they would put that on birth certificates
like, like when you say the original term, any of those people still alive?
Like is that still on somebody who's alive? Birth certificate.
That's a good question. Do people with downs syndrome live less?
They don't live as long, right? I think that's the case. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Do you want, you don't see a lot of older people
don't know this. Like we're tightening up the word.
I just can't wait till we can read minds.
So this all this nonsense just go out the window.
I think once we could read minds and then you just see intent and there's no
like words like cause right now it's just words that convey intent.
Some of those words are forbidden but some of those words have like bitch
perfect example. Like you could say that was a bad bitch. This bitch is crazy.
Like this bitch is fine. You know, you could say this bitch is hot,
this bitch is cool. That pitches so cool. Or You could say, oh my God,
this girl's a bitch, you know? Yeah. The connotations completely deaf.
There's so many of them. There's so many different ones where it's man,
where is it? A high thing. I remember one time Mickey Chill, Mickey, Joe,
Shelley and Mickey Call Joe.
Shelley and I were talking about about words and perceptions and like,
like your shirt, your shirt is green. Right.
But if I would be in your consciousness,
well I see your shirt and what I see it as as you read, but I,
I know it is green. You know what I mean? To me for sure.
Same colors are the same thing. No we don't. You have no way of knowing. Right,
right.
I have no had knowing what like some people were into weird shit like yellow
cars. Right. That's not weird though. That's weird.
All the colors to paint a car. Like why the fuck do you want a yellow car?
Like a nice car. Like you see like a yellow corvette. Like,
what the fuck are you doing to that corvette?
I swear you would go to say something different. I swear. I was like,
he's like people listen to people in the weird,
I thought you were going to say like
scat or something. They're definitely into that. The yellow cars.
That's not so bad. Yeah. But I mean I don't know what they're seeing.
Like to me a yellow car is like Ah, it's unfortunate,
you know like why would you do with that coverage?
Like maybe it was us on sale cause it's a shitty color.
I think that so yellow class should cost less. Yeah, for sure.
Yeah.
Unless you're just trying to make a point like your car is like a bumblebee or
something,
you know like you have black stripes and yellow and see how it'd be cool on a
bug on a Mustang. I don't know what else.
I think those are the only two cause they really should be yellow. A Mustang.
Like if you've got a painted like with um, some flames on it.
I don't even like you don't like mustangs? I'm not a big muscle car guy.
I do like sports cars. I'm not crazy about muscle cars. Somebody needs doctrine,
nature to the world of muscle cars that you just haven't seen the right ones.
You know, I think,
I think that comes from where I grew up because like you need a lot of open road
to that and we don't have that in the Bob. And like,
especially now where I'm from, like I am not a big fan of, um, of like choppers.
I'm not, I don't want those seem silly to me. Like you can't turn. Yeah,
I like crotch rockets and, and dirt bikes. This shit drives me crazy
handles and you're holding if for people just listening,
they have handlebars that are above your fucking head. Yeah. You're, hey,
you're driving around like this and you, if you have to turn quick your fuck,
how can you get away from shit? And once it goes bad it'll like you,
you're not gonna recover. Yeah.
I would think they would have like a secondary handle that you would have to
ride like that. You get tired. I have some shit right over the gas, foals out.
Maybe we can do that.
We could patent that and make that and probably make millions of dollars.
Somebody like skill.
That crotch rocket seems safer because they're more maneuverable. Yeah.
Like you can handle those motherfuckers. Those things move good. Yeah.
Especially, I mean as what they designed for. If you control it of high speed.
I saw this video of a, of a motorcross,
I don't know what you call when crotch rockets are racing,
but these guys were racing and the students that he was losing it and he got
thrown off. I saw that. But he was on his knees sideways.
He hung on their man and it looks like he was still giving it the gas. Yeah.
Yeah. I don't know. I don't know what the rules are or like cutting the track.
Right. But like if, if that, if he wasn't disqualified, that was an Indian move.
How do you get back on though? You'd have to slow down. You have to, right?
You got to do the Ninja move. You gotta hit the brake real hard.
So you slamming, then you, your body shoots into data land back on the bike.
The break and pop your hips up at the same time,
like something you'd see on fast and furious. I'm scared of bikes.
I don't know how to ride. You know? I mean, I could ride a bicycle,
but I can't ride a motorcycle. I can't ride a car.
I've never written a crotch rocket. I only written scooters. You know what?
They're making them electric now. You won't even, there's no gears.
It's just like a Tesla. But I don't, I don't like, I don't know.
The whole thing about riding a bike is being able to control it, isn't it? Well,
you can still control the speed, but you're not going to be able to shift gears.
You don't have to
do the shit with your left foot where you're going with the clutch and up and
down, all that jazz. You have to learn how to do that.
You don't have to do that with one of those things. It's brain. Yeah,
that'd be fucking ridiculously fast too.
I feel like I would be like the guy on and you know,
and like when you go to David,
most of the stuff on the motorcycle video. Yeah, yeah. In the,
in Europe they're making cars like electric cars have noise.
You have to have noise, like a regular car so that people could hear you.
That's dumb. Yeah. Well, yeah. I mean you're not riding on the sidewalk,
right? Yeah. Well I, yeah, I mean I guess it's,
if people are crossing streets and shit.
Um, maybe also, I don't know what the,
what the rules in Europe offer ride motorcycles. But um, I dunno.
Do you hear guys when they're riding on the, on the, in between lanes?
You know what I mean?
I don't hear them all the time. There's a lot of times where you don't,
you have to look in la. That's such a,
when I grew up in Boston and you couldn't do that, that's not legal.
Everybody has to stay in the lane. Really? Yeah. In Texas it's legal. Oh,
is splitting lanes? Yes. I don't know how often it's legal versus illegal.
Well, there's a lot of states that don't even, you don't have to wear helmets.
Yeah. Texas was one of them.
I don't know if that's changed and the Louisiana has one. That's crazy.
When I was in my last time I was in Miami,
I was watching dudes fly by me on the highway with no hell. And I'm like,
oh no though. I mean, do you, do you want a helmet on?
You hit something at 90 miles an hour. I don't know. Um,
I mean yes and no. It's like, I think sometimes people make it,
you know? Yeah.
But like what about you get all that pain was as Jamie [inaudible],
California remains the only state to allow lane splitting. Oh Wow.
So I guess is no longer that. I think you can just do it whenever you want.
It's on the motorcyclists to be risk at your, and you take your own risks. Oh,
so account in California is legal. Yeah. But in all the other places it's just,
you just kind of do it probably. I mean, yeah,
where it says immediately crossing the state line. There is,
nobody crosses the state
out here too. I don't know. Maybe it's partially legal there or something.
Certain cities areas. Yeah. Freeway maybe only or something
like, um, traffic laws. It's weird. Traffic laws being different,
like so different in every state. I was,
I'm in Texas a couple of days ago and I'm driving and I'm getting over cause the
cops pull somebody over. I'm on the highway and passenger.
She's like, why are you getting over? Like you don't have to do that.
But in Texas you're supposed to, if you, if you can get over,
you're supposed to get over and give them that lane birth.
Otherwise you slowed out to like 10 miles below the speed limit or whatever. Um,
but like in DC, Maryland wishes from, it's like you don't have to do that.
Like, but it's like if I'm from, if I'm from Maryland,
I'm in Texas and I do that and then another cops behind me,
I'm getting a ticket. Cause if you don't know the law, it's not the law.
It's still not their fault. Right, right. It's your fault for not following
the Hong Kong protests that are going on. No,
this crazy protests going on in Hong Kong. But what's, uh,
amazing is there was an ambulance and the ambulance was trying to,
I mean this giant crowds in the street.
I mean fucking thousands if not a million people. Right.
They part like the see for this, for this ambulance. It's crazy.
Like if that shit was happening in America, good luck.
You can blow that horn all you want. What does this, Jamie,
you're gonna have to run this it. Yeah. Mm. Why?
It's, why does it say north point, not like Chinese characters on the street?
Yeah. You sure? This is the one, I mean,
Hong Kong protest is Bockwoldt may wait for him. I saw an overhead shot of it.
It was more impressive because it was this giant sea of people and they all just
made way and everybody got right the fuck out of the way for ambulances.
It's like when a predatory fish swims to like a small school. Oh, here it is.
This, this is what I saw. Yeah. So these people just open up.
Good luck trying that shit in America. I mean,
these people were so polite. Millions of protesters.
They're like two to 3 million or something. Yeah. What do they do?
You know what they're protesting over. I can't,
there's so much outrage worldwide. I can't keep track man. Yeah.
There's stuff going on everywhere.
You see that there's this stuff in Sudan right now. Everywhere.
You know every part of the world is up in arms, Gaza.
There's a bunch of shit going on in there and going off every new,
more recent shit. It's exhausting.
I was like, why can't people just not be assholes? Right. That's impossible.
That's what we need. This mind reading software.
The problem with that is like then you just reading the mind of assholes. Maybe,
maybe,
but maybe people can let you know like hey man do you don't have to think like
that.
Your problem is the way you thinking cause it's 90% of the problem with people's
the way they think and then they act on the way they think.
I Dunno if at 90% of them are really not a mathematician just threw that number
out there. They get to locked up.
Yesterday I showed you is sort of on the way to what you're talking about,
how your friends can play a video game together using only your minds. Okay.
This is what you were talking about after the show. Telepathic communication.
Yeah. This is, this is the future. 100%.
There's going to be a time where we share some sort of,
I think it's going to be some sort of a universal language.
They're going to create a language, it's based on images or,
or things that are culturally like you could,
it could cross boundaries like people from other countries is going to be able
to understand that.
You'll be able to understand it has like Google translate in it. Yes.
I really think that, I think there's gonna be a language.
I mean like do you ever see someone's tweet?
I read tweets from people all the time from different countries.
It's kind of cool that you could like read some Russian,
see some Russian shit and then just say translate the tweet and you get a chance
to try to figure out what this guy is saying. Yeah, I've seen
that a couple of times. And then, especially with, um, some of my teammates,
friends, Brazilian guys, and um, they will have it in Portuguese,
but they will also translate have it in English. Brazilian girls do that.
But then when you translate it, it'll like,
it moves words that are already in the English translation.
It makes it like screwed up. It makes it like the grammar is all messed up.
It's really weird. I Dunno why,
why it even touches the English if you bring it to that language, you know,
that's the problem with languages, right?
Like the way they say things is different.
And so trying to translate something to English,
you have to take some sort of editorial license.
You'd have to move things around. What you're trying to say is this,
you can't just translate it. Yeah. Yeah.
Especially because of like where we place like prepositions and like there are
some like, um, there are some languages where they don't have the word off.
Like don't, they don't, they don't say turn off the light.
And it's like when they said when they speak in English, they say,
kill the light, you know? Well, that's the way,
I mean, you could still get it, but yeah. That if they don't have an off word,
like I would imagine that Asians,
like Asian language is going to be the hardest, right.
Because they have characters, they don't even have letters, you know? Yeah.
They, their alphabet so much,
so much bigger and their characters can mean so many different things.
This little piece of a character combined with this changes everything.
It changes each one individually.
Like it's like this one is water and this one is fire and you put them together
and it's chocolate. When you were fighting, what was the place you,
how many times, different times did you travel overseas to fight? Seven,
six or seven, something like that. Was there any, what was the weirdest place?
Weirdest. Most different was Japan, but, um,
I wouldn't say it was weird. Just different. Just different. Yeah,
very different. It was like being in the future sometimes. Yeah. Right. Yeah.
Tokyo. Yeah. You're like, I don't know. It was a lot of fun.
The different things they do.
They're the weirdest thing about being over there was that, that Pachinko game,
like what's Pachinko gets like these people they play, they,
it's like a gambling game and um,
they have these buckets of like ball bearings and I put them in the game and I
don't, I don't even know what the rules are.
But you see like older and middle aged Japanese people,
they just sit there for hours just playing and you win. And it's like,
I'm like winning a slice, like a slot machine kind of. Right. So when you win,
like you get a bunch of these, these balls back, I swear to you if you like,
I don't know if Jamie pulled up like something, but it's,
I think it's p a Chenko Oh, sorry.
Here's a guy who's hands biggest gaming obsession explained Pachinko they're
like putting ball-bearings in there and they just go for all words.
That's what many people are wearing masks.
That's the other weird thing about the age. You're right.
They know a lot of people like to wear those masks. So, so that's the game.
That thing that they're this weird, how's it work? Did you play it?
No, I mean, I don't know. I don't know what you're trying to do.
Like everything's in Japanese. That's the currency for the game.
Those ball-bearings I don't understand. Can't believe,
I'm just finding out about this and you'll see,
you'll see somebody sitting there and they will have buckets like,
like this big like square rectangular buckets and they'll have like two or three
stacks of them next to them and they just reached down and drop them in the
machine and that's how they play. I don't know what they're doing though.
I don't understand it at all. I want to play it, but then I'm like,
you look stupid. I don't want to win ball bearings. What am I going to do?
Put it in my car.
Yeah. What the fuck look at that is so strange.
A buckets guys just taken fists of ball bearings and throwing them into this
machine and then the bounce it around like a,
like a pinball machine turned up on its side.
Yeah, I, I don't, I don't understand it at all. I don't know. Like,
what's the value on this
all there, dude, I don't look, every time I go to Vegas,
every time I go through casino I freak out. I just, I just see those people.
I feel like they're wasting their life playing those goddamn slot machines.
Yeah. Yeah. That's the first time I went to, the first time I fought in Vegas,
I, um, I played a slot machine. Um, as the only time I,
I did the first time I gambled like in The Bahamas when I was growing up.
Also Bahamians couldn't even gamble in The Bahamas.
But then I came here and I was in Vegas and I was like, I want to play slots.
But I was like against gambling. So I played the nickel slots for awhile.
How about 20 bucks a N***a slots? I Bet I'm shaking my, my,
my winnings and people's faces like, oh, that's hilarious.
You got to go to like circus circus at some place to play the nickel slots.
Do you ever go to that place? I bet, yeah. I've stayed at circus circus,
but that's a window into history. Yes.
I go to circus circus every time I go to Vegas with my kids,
because my youngest daughter likes going there.
She likes playing all those stupid carnival games. She thinks it's hilarious.
She's nine, you know? Yup.
She likes shooting water at the thing and the pops and all that stuff's,
we always go there, but it's always,
and then they do like a circuit show or they'll have like a clown and trapeze
artists, but it's like, no disrespect, but it's kind of second rate,
you know, like the trapeze guy's got a gut. Yeah. Well, I mean,
you know, he's a little thick around the Middle East.
His best days of flipping around to the air over he's got, yeah, the big gut.
The long arms. Yeah. Yeah. That's,
I don't know, it's especially when you compare, when you say second rate,
especially when you compare it to like blue man group or what's going on at like
Mandalay and GM or something. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. But I mean a, it's,
you're, you're still on the strip. You're not on Fremont. Like Freelon is like,
Fremont is like, like second rate Vegas. It's very different.
Very weird. I um,
I remember and like I know how many probably kids in flack for this,
but I gotta tell you this story. Like I'm, I'm a,
I was there one time and I'm telling my friends about like, I'm like,
this is weird cause like I've never really been to Fremont until this time in
Vegas and I'm just like, man, why aren't we on the strip?
This is just so weird being out here. What was there for some fights?
I was like, everything is just a little
different. I mean like everything's really like everything's really different.
I mean look like even the women like look at that girl, she's like,
she's so like [inaudible] she hasn't got a great body. Right? It's like so fine.
Then she turned around and she's like, her face is just like ruined, you know?
Like it's not my fault. I mean she wasn't attractive to me and she,
I'm sure she's attracted to somebody.
It's hard to say that these days you used to be able to say someone's ugly.
You can still say it. Dude's ugly. Nobody gives you a hard time.
You can still say a dude's fat or a dudes ugly. Everybody's like, fine,
no problem. Fat All the time. No one has a problem with that. Yeah.
Fat and ugly for a guy, it's fine. But if you say a girl's fat,
your body shaming, if you say she's ugly,
you're a fucking sexist piece of shit and you're objectifying her. Yeah.
I, it's, it's really hard. I mean like, there was this,
there's this lady who's a, who's a singer, her name is Lizzo, right. Um,
Big Lady, uh, a bigger lady, a plus size woman. Right. And, um, she,
that woman that was on the bet awards, she's fucking talented. Yes.
Woo. Right. And like, see, here's the thing, like Jesse,
she's a plus size woman. Um, some people think she, that's overweight,
but I'm like, she's not obese. So it's like, I mean, she,
she's like gross grotesquely obese. I guess that's how you'd say grossly obese.
She could lose a few pounds. She could if she wanted to, but like there's there,
there like there's, there's definitely some,
there's definitely plenty of guys in the world who that suits, you know, um,
there are some guys my size with that suits.
There are some guys who are like linebacker alignments size who that suits,
but then there are, they're like, nobody,
nobody complains about the petite woman.
But like what about like the big linebacker guy who was into petite women? Like,
yeah. Well, you know that dude the mountain from game of Thrones,
his girlfriend or his wife or whatever she is, she's like three feet tall
and he's a fucking child. Yeah. Yeah. Like you see that sometimes.
I think the guy that played Chewbacca, like the original Chewbacca,
I think his wife was, was a tiny woman. Like not like a midget or anything,
but I'm in trouble now. Yeah,
there's a, that's the mountain. Wow. That guy actually, you know what,
she might be normal size. Yeah. He's so fucking big,
which she's going to be heels on there at a gala, but uh,
he's so fucking big like that right there. That looks like me.
With my nine year old. Yeah, it does. It does. That's height wise.
That guy is so God damn biggest ridiculous.
Like if you cut off his body where her head is,
he would still probably be twice her size. Twice her weight. Oh yeah. For sure.
Yeah. A big fella. Yeah.
He's always entering those strong man competitions.
These the most ridiculous thing to watch. You know, whenever I'm like bored,
flip it to the channels and I catch some dude throwing a beer barrel over over a
pole. You know there's always a suspended pole thrown over the top of it.
Like a, like a high jump pole. So ridiculous. Yeah,
I but those, those
kind of type of competitions you talk about like,
like that there's that and then you have that for the athletic or dynamic people
like American Ninja Warrior.
Yeah. Oh that's an intellect. That's fucking interesting man. Yeah.
Those Ninja Warrior and warrior shows are crazy.
Watch those guys you love that is some serious fucking athleticism too.
We'll do that.
Yeah, that, that, that, that's a whole sport now.
Like they create gyms based around that and people that are like,
like training for it. I do with a training. Yeah.
For the trials. Yeah. No I can imagine there's probably you up.
I wonder, I'd like to know like who's the best at that weight class wise.
I bet it's guys that are like 160 pounds and under. Yeah. Cause Yeah,
you carry yourself easy. Cause we,
we did a study on fear factor once where you had to a,
they were suspect they were off a bridge and they had to hold,
just hold themselves like on a chin up bar over a bridge.
And the girls all beat the guys wait. They were just hanging,
just hanging, not just himself. Nope. Wow. Okay. Just hanging. Huh?
Just holding on. The girls all beat the guys, the all three guys fell.
Now it's like, part of me was like, maybe these guys are just bitches.
But part of me was like, well the thing is like the guys,
they're pretty big dudes.
They're all around 200 plus pounds and uh, you know,
that's a lot of weight in your hands. And the girls are like one 2110,
one oh five, it's not as much weight.
There's, there's uh,
a genetic thing between men and women where there are some things that like we
all, we, we see these in sports and whatnot.
There are some sports that are just much more fun to watch when men are playing
or some sports for fun with women playing.
There are some sports that are both right. Right. But um, there was something,
I forget the test exactly,
but it's something about leaning over and picking up a chair.
There's a certain posture that you're in and men can't do it, but a women can.
Huh? Like you can't end, but it's like a folding chair, like very,
very light chair. Um, I don't know. I don't leaning over and picking up. Yeah.
Like you're leaning, I think you press your head onto the wall,
but arch your back in a certain way and you,
you just have to use like your lats basically.
You pick up the chair and you and men can't do it. Really? Yeah.
Her weird. Yeah. It's cause it's like a center of gravity tests.
I remember just to say, you leave your butt. Oh yeah. You know,
my daughter tried to show me this the other day.
She tried to get me to touch my toes with,
keep my back flat against the wall of the back of my legs against the wall and
go down and touch your toes. You just fall forward. Yeah,
that's, that's, let's see. I had it all backwards. I'm like, Hey,
you put your butt against the wall, not your head.
Sticking my butt up against stuff. Let me see
that. Let me say tricks. Guys. Can't do stand three feet away from a wall.
Bend over. Put your head against the wall.
Now try to stand up while lifting a chair. Oh No, you had it. Okay.
That was a couple of different places. So yeah,
a couple of around the center of gravity though. Oh yeah.
That's the one I'm going to try. I feel like I could do that. That's, that's,
that's what I said. Yeah. I mean, I don't know.
I don't think I'm being cocky and saying I could do that.
But what if a guy's got like really core strength?
I don't think it has nothing to do with that. Yeah.
Just all about center of gravity. Yeah.
Cause I think not most guys black like you take a bunch of fit guys.
They have a good strong core. They can't do it and they can't do it.
Like it takes an average woman. Congratulations on your victory ladies.
You got us on one. Yeah, I don't,
I don't want to stay. That's what it was. Sensitive subjects where I'm like,
I don't want to say anything smart ass or anything, any kind of way.
Cause I get myself in trouble. So much trouble to get into today.
So many different things people get mad and upset about. They did a test with,
uh, the way that men and women do a one legged squat.
And I guess the way that each of us would go down,
it's completely different when you,
when you break it all the way down to that move. Oh, so like the mechanics,
is that because of the hips, muscle structure, everything? Yeah,
it probably is that with women, the, the,
it's so different the way the shape of their hips. They'll like the mechanic,
like women kicking. That's one.
Like for every Valentini shift Chanko that can knock someone out with one kick.
Yeah. You would think that a woman, right?
Take 140 pound woman who is carrying 140 pounds with her legs all the time,
going up flights of stairs, running,
doing all these different plyometrics and shit.
You would think that bitch could be able to kick a fucking hole through.
You see there's another use of the word bitch.
That's okay that it's out of respect. That's not a, that's not derogatory.
But no. Like if you see a girl kick a bag,
like there's a giant difference between 140 pound girl kicking a bag,
140 pound guy. Big Difference. And now, now,
is it mostly technique or is it, you know by, I think it's biomechanics.
I think it's technique. I think it's just muscles. There's,
they're just built different, there's just different muscles.
Like the hips are like this, right? Yeah. Tip. Especially for minutes,
wide hips, right.
Or their hips go out wide and their legs kind of go in a little bit.
Where's it got? I wonder if that's responsible for the, what do they call that?
The male spread.
When dudes sit on a sit on the subway and they spread the legs,
the man spread. Yeah,
they man spread and people get real mad cause they want to sit next to you and
your legs are all splayed out. You're being rude.
But if a dude has no one next to him, that's how they sit. Their legs spread.
I don't think women sit like that. I don't think,
I don't think it goes that way. No, I don't like sitting like that.
It's like as I sit and like I've sat in coach most of my life,
you know, and like that's, that's, it's uncomfortable.
Like when you have to sit like that for an extended amount of time,
it's really uncomfortable with the legs pinned together. Yeah. Yeah. It's weird.
Yeah. And then there are some times, but after a while you just, you,
you just feel uncomfortable inside your pants and you got,
you had to move stuff around. You can't even open your legs to do that.
But with women, I think that's a normal way to sit.
I think their body naturally with their hips in a shape that there are,
the legs kind of go towards other, they kind of point towards the knees.
It's more normal for them to sit with their legs together, the think. Hmm.
Does that make sense? It makes sense. I just,
I wonder if it has to do with anything that the equipment down there also
probably has to do with not wanting to be a ho. Right.
[inaudible] sit like this with your legs spread. If a dude sits like that,
that's a confident man. But if a girl is sitting there with the legs, be like,
look at this bitch. There's another use of the word bitch.
This isn't a scientific article explaining manspreading.
This is a spinal neurosurgeons explanation. Spinal neurosurgeon Johns.
The overall width of the pelvis is relatively greater in females and the angle
of the femoral neck is more acute.
These factors could play a role in making a position of sitting with the knees
close together. Less comfortable for men. Exactly.
So all you man spreading people that are shaming men for sitting in a natural
way. How dare you. You should be ashamed of yourself. I'm offended. Yeah.
I can't wait until women have all the powers so we can just start shitting on
them. So here's a subtle subtlety,
subtle thing about that. They kind of do, right? I have some,
it's like who's the world champion of your house? Yeah,
but that's just happy wife. Happy life. That's how you have to run that shit.
Yeah. Anytime you it. Otherwise it's just,
I've never seen another situation that works. Or you have like some,
some woman who just afraid she can't talk and you know,
you don't want that either. No, that's just not healthy. It's not healthy.
It's not like, how do you enjoy that? I don't know. You have to be a sick fuck.
Yeah. Yeah. I don't have my, my house is zero designed by me.
There's no decorations of mine is I have one mounted elk head. That's it.
The first elk ever shot with a bow and Arrow I have mounted. That's it.
Everything else fucking, I don't care. It looks good.
The first time they came through. You gave me some alchemy.
I made spaghetti out of it. It was some of the best spaghetti. I made.
Super good for your body, man. You could eat that shit all the time.
If you lived around here, I'd hook you up all the time. Yeah, I used to.
When I get back I'm gonna stop.
I'm just going to start hitting you up asking you failed me.
How long you in town for? I leave in the morning.
Do you have a place to cook tonight? Yeah, I got some food for you. Okay.
Okay. I've got some elk sausage that's out of this fucking world, right?
That's good. Yeah. I'm, I'm, I'm completely down man. The first time I was,
I was a little hesitant because I was like, well,
this didn't come from the store, so you know what I mean?
But then I took it home, I made it up and I was just like, Oh man, it,
the flavor is so different. Like the flavor is different,
the texture is different. Um, I don't know. I really, I wanted more, it's alive.
I mean in, in terms of like when you're eating,
it just feels like it's got energy. It's got power. Yeah. Like it,
like it tastes like it had a good life. Yeah man. Like if you are eating some,
some like a pig lives in a pen, like oh sad.
It's just sadness. You've eating an elk,
especially if you didn't know you were there like that.
I'll get no idea you were there until that Arrow hit his rib cage and then it's
dead in seconds that, that thing lived a noble life. Yeah. You know,
and that's the best way it's ever going to die. You don't want,
I mean if you're an elk,
you don't want to get caught in a valley with some walls. That shit's rough.
That's a rough way to go.
I was talking to you buddy Jeff earlier about that.
I'm like, hello. You got a choice, right? You get, you're good. Of course.
Hypothetically you got a choice. You're going to,
you're going to get mauled by a beer, a gorilla, um,
or die by wolf or a tiger. What do you
well, I'll take the gorilla all day cause I think it's just gonna beat your ass.
I don't think he's going to kill you because I don't think,
I don't think he wants to eat you,
but like the premise of the question is you're going to die. Hmm. Yeah.
Then the tiger, cause the tiger is going to get your neck and kill you quick.
That's, that's my choice also. I think so.
You in the video of the tiger chasing the dudes on a motorbike? No.
Oh in India it's horrific.
It's fucking dudes are driving on this road in this a wildlife preserve and this
tiger comes full clip chasing them out of the jungle and just bales off at the
last second. Just can't catch them. Shit. It should.
It's fucking horrific.
They're so fast. Like what do you do? Right. Okay.
Then you do like when you can do let's you have a gun, you're so weak.
It's not much you can do, but then when you think about that, they're like,
you think about Africa, you think about any,
you think about these places where lions and tigers exist and people have
existed since the beginning of time. At some point someone had to win that,
right?
Just, Oh, just numbers. Just population numbers. Here's the video.
Check this shit out. You're going to freak out. I don't need to see her, Jamie.
Here it is. So these guys,
oh, this thing just, oh,
he just tried. He tried.
Now the reason why this is significant is because in India,
tigers eat people all the fucking time.
They eat them all the time. Like there's tigers that target human beings.
There's a place in India called the Sunderbans and the Sunderbans is um,
it's near this river that they,
they think that one of the reasons why the Tigers are so irritable is that
they're drinking this river water and the river water has a high degree of salt
in it, high level salt. And so they're irritated all the time.
They're just in the agony and they're particularly vicious.
And over the last 200 years,
tigers have killed more than 300,000 human beings in this one part of it.
Like why do you still live there? Like I'm giving the more, you know,
I'm giving them, I'm giving that place to the Tigers. I S I see that,
I see that video and I imagine being that guy on that bike and like I,
you know what a bike seat is like, right? Yeah. Cute. Cute.
Imagine being on a bike seat with like, what? Ha like I'm shitting myself. Yeah.
You know, if you have any shit in your body, it's gonna come out.
Like there's no way you win that. Nope. No Way. You win that. Not Today.
No, you don't win. You only win
by being on the Mar. So I go and get, in a way,
the fact they got a video of it though. Yeah. How'd he,
I hope we had a GoPro line. He's a, he's like, just like riding. Hey,
they listen, they get, they get got all the time. All the time.
Especially in India.
India I think is the worst place in the world for Tiger in human interactions.
I don't get that. Like other tigers in India.
Bigger Tigers. Yeah, it does. I know it doesn't matter the size,
like they're even like 300 or 500 pounds or something like that.
Think the biggest tigers are in Siberia. Okay.
But I think that's the case. Usually with mammals,
what happens is the like the same species when they're in a hotter climate tend
to be smaller.
Depends on the animal obviously than they are in the colder climates.
It's something that has something to do with preserving body temperature.
Like deer for instance.
Like if you get a whitetail deer from Texas,
it's much smaller than a whitetail deer from Saskatchewan.
So same species, but way up north they just, it's just colder and they grow,
grow. They'll grow like 300 pounds up there. Whereas like a big white town,
Texas like half that size. Yeah.
The people to certain places with people that just the mountain guy from game of
Thrones. That motherfucker. Yes.
A controversial moment. Uh, the end of last year into this year,
they had a tiger that was known for killing 13 people or more and so they had a
shoot to kill a target on it and I guess they,
someone got it and people are mad. People were,
it killed 13 people and people were mad that someone killed it.
People are just fucking weak. They're just so soft.
What if you got the wrong tiger? Fuck him. Fuck them all killed.
Whenever anyone that you get a chance to kill that's close enough to kill you
kill them man. I think I, I I key, I can't get that,
that video of the tiger chasing that bike out of my head. Cause like,
like that's another thing. Those things,
they're so coordinated that thing at full speed can take a swipe at that back
tire and just [inaudible] and then you're screwed. And they're like,
what do you do?
Cause you like what's your first reaction going to be like get up and try and
get back on the bike. There's nothing you can do. There's nothing you can do.
There's no way you get the bike going.
And time the tiger would be on you so fast they can run,
they could probably run 40 miles an hour. Those fucking things. Yeah.
And it's probably 400 pounds, 500 pounds,
400 pounds of something.
An animal that's 400,000 pounds and runs at twice the speed of Usain bolt.
How is that fair? I mean, that's why there's not a million deer.
You know,
the reason why that a million deer in that same spot is because of those tigers.
They need them. You know, I was um, in Lanai,
which is one of the islands in Hawaii,
hunting a access deer and the access deer were given to King Kamehameha of
Hawaii like in the 18 hundreds. And when we were over there,
you know, you bow hunt these things and I'm telling you,
you've never seen a deer move this fast. Yeah.
The reason why they're so fast as they evolved to get away from tigers,
so when they see you there,
they make these noise like bay and then they fucking scattered and there's so
fast. Like it's hilarious to watch. Like, wow, they're so fast.
When you say that, like my brain just starts doing the math and I'm like,
like of course the ones that got caught by the tigers are the slower ones. Yeah.
So like the fastest ones. Amazing. Yeah. Like, yeah,
I can only imagine it's,
it's Kinda like I'm a Olympic sprinter,
female Olympic Sprinter, Mary's uh, uh,
running back and they have a kid. Whoo. Yeah. Look, genetics are real. I mean,
that's one of the reasons why Americans becoming softer and softer is cause what
are you getting?
You getting people that sit at a desk all day with fucking herniated discs in a
fat belly,
drinking coffee and eating donuts and they marry someone who's just like them
and they barely get their shit together.
And they have a kid who watches video games all day and eat cookies and,
and he's gross. And then he marries another girl who's like that.
And next thing you know, you go through this four or five, six generations,
you get, you got piss poor jeans. Yeah. I, um,
I just recently went home to The Bahamas and I,
I'm starting to miss it more and more and more because as I get older,
I long for the things that I did as a little kid.
I love for the places that I was at as a little kid.
And so my family's from this little place called farmer Ski Exuma that's three
quarters of a mile by seven, eight.
I think I told you that before and it's tiny and I was there this time.
And just seeing, just,
just waking up every morning and just looking out the window and just blue ocean
all day. Um, I just, I want to go back there. The people that people,
the people that live there, like you get a boat at like 14,
15 years old because there's really nothing that you can do on the island other
than interact with the family and fish, right? Everything, everything,
everything that you need stabilized, you have to go somewhere else to get her.
It has to be brought in. So like, I have a cousin who, um, he's like,
he's older than me. He's like my grandmother's generation, but he's my cousin.
Um, he's like four years older than me, but like this guy,
he free dives and he will go down and he will hang out on the water for like two
or three minutes. Like with this, with a spear. He doesn't,
he doesn't like to school. He doesn't like to take, um, take a tank with him.
One time we were fishing off the back of the boat.
He's off the front and he's like, he ended and then on top of that he's in,
he's in the water and he read, he comes out and when he reaches up he says,
Hey Julian, bring the boat over here. It's a shock. So like there's not as like,
but, and then he goes back down, you know what I mean?
Does it shock in the water near, I'm probably a reef shark and um,
he's got his spear and he's just like, just get closer, but I'm still fishing.
Like that's, that's the life.
So he just wants to be able to get out if shit goes sideways. Yeah, I,
I'm assuming, but I'm like scared.
Would you think that it would be safer to be in the water or on top of the
water? If there was a shark, like if you had goggles,
you could see the motherfucker. Wouldn't you want to be in the water?
Do you need it then on top and not knowing where he's coming from?
I would think so. I would think so.
But then you like not only is it three 60 but it's like universal.
The view is universal. Right, right.
But if you're on top of the water and you can see at least is like you've got
your back to the wall and you can't come from the top. That's true.
So that's true. I don't know.
But at the same time you're in the water with an animal who's who.
That's his natural habitat. Yeah. Like you can't,
you can't even turn around nearly as fast as he can.
He can probably swim around you and come up from the back before you could even
turn around. Yeah, probably. Yeah. They swim pretty fucking fast. Yeah.
They're like Ninjas in the water to just clean the cleanup crew.
Just like the tiger. I am. So I girlfriend and I were there and I was, um,
feeding the turtles, right?
So I try to grab a turtle and literally the turtle is this big.
It's no bigger than this. And I'm about to pick it up.
I'm trying to pick it up being like explaining to people, oh, I'm sorry. Yeah,
I'm probably like trust 16 inches. Leon trashcan lit no bigger than a trashcan.
And I am trying to pick it up and this before I can get it out of the water.
Those are the big fins arms that they have. He just,
he pulls me down into the water like this, this little thing.
He probably weighs 40, 50 pounds, right? And it's just so powerful in the water.
Like if I were to hang onto that turtle,
I would be moving faster than I would move with fins on. Like,
how was that po? And I'm like, I don't want to talk about my weight,
but I'm a lot bigger than that. He can sensitive.
I am, I'm not fight weight. And you're eating well. You look good man.
Don't worry about it. Do you think you're gonna move to Bahamas?
You think you'd live there someday? Um, I like, ultimately,
I definitely want to live back there in my lifetime. You know, I, um, I mean I,
if I want to, I want to die there. Whoa. You know what I mean?
I don't necessarily want to die anytime soon, but,
but when you do you want to live the end of your life there? Relaxed life,
island life. Hey Man, I get it. Every time I go to Hawaii,
my brain starts spinning. I'm like, can I live here? Why don't I just move here?
I'm like, I don't, I don't need much. You know, you, you had,
did you watch the Steve Jobs movie? No, I haven't either.
But just recently it was on television and the f the opening scene was some guy
in like, I don't know,
the seventies or sixties talking about computers when computers were huge,
when computers were like as big things and take up an entire room.
And he's like, yeah, one day.
Like you can be anywhere in the world and you can work,
you can be on a remote island and you can be doing your work and you will get
emails. You're talking about emails
like in the 60s, you know,
he's talking about the internet in the sixties or something.
It's on the beginning of the jobs movie. And I'm like one with Ashton Kutcher.
No,
I said I was gonna ask which one? There's another one fast.
Michael Fassbender too, that came out. I think it's the Fastbender.
I don't know what Michael Fassbender, it looks like. I know that name,
but it's Michael Fassbender. He's a, what was he in? I build,
I think he's like Loki and the Avengers, I think I asked him to, Oh,
let me somebody. Yeah, I think that makes sense.
I think that's him. But yeah, that, that movie. Um,
they were talking about that then and I'm like, you know,
and then 2001 was when, um, jobs came out with a, yeah, that's him.
Oh No, no. It's easy. Loki. So he's someone, but I picked somebody up,
but he's from prometheus's. Okay. So robot in the promiscuous and alien series.
He's the a, Oh yeah, that guys. Excellent. Yeah. Oh,
so he played a bunch of stuff with Steve Jobs and asshole in the Steve jobs
movie.
Yeah. I mean, I only saw like the first five minutes I want to watch this,
but in the middle he does look. Yeah, he is in the movie.
But the claim is that you have to be an asshole to be like a genius. Right,
right.
I don't know if I buy that either.
A lot of people who get a lot of shit done eventually run into people that don't
get shit done the way they want and so the only way they figure out how to get
shit done with those people is to dominate them. Yeah.
Plunkett to yell at them and to, you know,
like the apple deal was that you had to work insane hours too.
That's a weird thing, man. If you're going to work for a company,
you got a good job. Is it a good job?
What's so good about it that you getting money? Where's your life?
You don't have a life, you, you're working 17 hours a day. Oh, okay.
That sucks. That's a shitty job. Even if you make it a lot of money,
like a guy who makes less money but it can take the weekend off and go fishing
and hang out with his kids and chill. That's a better life. Preach it Joe.
Preach it. That's a better life. I'm listening. Hallelujah.
That Bahamas life is the way to go. I'm telling you,
you got me thinking when I went on when I was at [inaudible]
home is it was just nice like a fighter's.
A fighter's life is kind of like that. I mean, not,
not all the time and not every one,
but you get to do what you love to do and then you get to do what you want do,
if you can handle the highs and the lows with fighters,
it's handling the highs with the ego and the lows with the emotions and the,
just the letting everybody down and the depression
that both of those things, that's like, those are the extremes, but that,
that the highs of, of winning big fights and, and have getting,
being admired for something that really truly becomes a part of you just just
being yourself. Yeah. That, that feels good.
But you do put a lot of weight on yourself and,
and when you lose, like, I ain't gonna lie, man. Um, there,
there has been some things on the Internet, like when I lost the harmonic,
right. I was like, oh, he threw that fighting and I like, like
that, that breaks my heart. That hurts when someone says you through the phone.
Yeah. You can just can't read that shit. But I know what you mean. Yeah.
You can't read this. People that they have crazy theories about nonsense.
You know,
that's crazy that the idea that you threw a fight or the you would get together
with hot or making a bet against yourself or something stupid like that.
So I just heard, I just heard, um,
at some point over the past year or so, I heard a, an argument that like,
well,
if a guy doesn't make weight and the other guy gets so much of his purse,
like, and he's going to get his winning show money, right?
If he's guaranteed is winning show money anyway,
then why wouldn't he just throw the fight and get a bonus percentage of the
winners win money. And that's the more on
it's a moron. Well, not only that, the thank you, that's not just a moron.
It's someone who doesn't understand the psychology of a winner. Yeah. Like the,
the thing about a winner is a little lasting.
A winner wants to do is lose on purpose. Right.
And when you have the opportunity, the, the big thing is winning.
You have the opportunity to win.
It's right in front of you and you only get a chance to do this three times a
year, four times a year, five of your cowboy, right? Like right.
Like how many times does he, he's crazy. He's crazy.
But he fights like five times a year. Right. If he could,
he'd probably fight every week. Yeah. But the,
the idea that you're going to throw that,
the, the, the best feeling that you could ever achieve.
They're crazy. They just don't understand it.
But that's just the problem with the Internet is reading comments. Yes.
To any morons with ideas. I used to love the underground man. It was great.
Back in the day I was like, how am I, like I had the old one,
I had think I've double o's. You know what I mean? Yeah.
Like being and being from back then, you know? Yeah.
Maybe even in 90 like they at some point they just gave you the number that was
on in the nineties same here. Yeah. So like,
I don't know if my thing says 99 or [inaudible] I still sign in every once in a
while just to check in, just to check in. So it's toxic conversation,
but that's just the Internet in general.
There's still a lot of good discussions on the underground lot of thing.
Last time was on was about a month ago I went and checked. I was like, hmm.
Like there was some, especially there was some good Jujitsu talk.
There was some good technique. Talk about like leg locks and,
and you know, and whether or not there's going to be a, uh,
transition from leg locks because everybody's,
the leg lock game sort of overtook Jujitsu, whether or not it was going to, uh,
switch to choking or when someone's like,
whether it's going to going to be a new trend because the leg lock defense is so
good now. And I'm like, I appreciate that.
I appreciate it when people are like devoted practitioners and they're really
discussing technique and disco. But when it's like,
this guy's a pussy and he fuck, it sucks. And you know, Rhonda,
Rosie's a fucking bitch. And like, dude,
there's so much that on the Internet it's hard
to um, to filter through that to find some good conversations sometimes. Yeah.
It's like in your life you would avoid people like that, like the plague.
Like if there was a guy in your life that wanted your phone number and all he
does is complain about things and have stupid theories get this guy the fuck
away from me. Right? Yeah. But you can't avoid them online. Yeah,
no online. That's the thing that, that, you know,
being anonymous on the Internet, that's some power for some people, man.
Sure. When it's crazy. Well it's also,
you got to realize that the people that are executing that power,
the people that want and need that power,
they're all either young or they're losers.
Those are the two that either young and they don't get it. You know,
they're 14 someone lets them online.
They just want to say mean shit cause it's fun. Like you gotta you gotta Rock,
there's a window. Ah, yeah. I was looking at my throw this rock.
That's what people do. It's normal,
but I don't want to hang out with young kids and I don't want to hang out with
losers. But see that's the problem. I think there's something with that too,
that, um, I mean, let me,
we know there's something with that where that being anonymous, you,
that's a protection. Like you see, sometimes I bleeds into their real life.
I mean, I saw this, this video of this kid, he's like,
he's just like making fun of this older man. He was,
he's being rude to this woman. He's making fun of this old man, man.
So the man I making fun of him too. He's like, Amy, me, me, me.
That's so the kid starts punching him in the arm and the guy's like,
he just turns away. Kids punches swinging at him.
And this is not like a little kid. He's, he's, he's a little kid. You shouldn't,
he's not a kid that you would smack because if he started talking smack to you,
right, you didn't fight him because of that.
But then this kid starts punching him and he's like, he's like,
he tells the kid to stop and the kid keeps going and grabbing my throat and he
pushes him, right? And the kid falls down and he's like,
and then he starts crying and I, you assaulted me. And it's like, like,
what? What reality do you live in man? Like your parents have failed. Like,
I'm sorry. You know, life failed them. They live in a blurry reality.
It's too much online. Not enough real world. Yeah. Like not enough.
Getting your ass kicked as the thing. Fighting solves everything. Man.
Solves a lot of things. Everything. I hate those people that say fight fighting.
What is that going to solve? Like everything I'm telling you,
like my thing is like if you start, if I don't like going back and forth,
you know what I mean? Like we're not going to go back and forth.
You say something disrespectful. I'm going to say something disrespectful.
I'm going up the [inaudible] and then if you want to keep going, like, man,
we can just stop talking right now and go, yeah. You know, I know I'm, I'm,
I'm an old man now,
but like I think that solves everything.
Like there's no reason to be talking.
Also having a history of that and your life gives you a much better perspective
of the consequences of talking shit if you don't have any history.
Like how many times have you seen guys talk shit and you know they can't fight.
No. Yeah, this is crazy. This is like someone challenging someone to a race.
They've never driven a car. Like they don't even know how to shift gears.
So you don't know a god damn thing what you watch a Jackie Chan movie thinking
to fuck somebody up.
But there's a lot of people there. Yeah.
Doing this. So many people that believe that like,
and then just guys will watch fights. Like they believe that they can beat,
they, they,
they're legit people that believe they can beat people that are inside the
octagon or inside a professional cage inside the PFL or rising or somewhere and
they're just like, I could beat that guy. No,
you can't really believe that just by being poly mile. Naji did you see?
You know? No, he'll fuck
queue up. That was a sad fight, man. I've watched.
I watched it again. I didn't watch. I didn't, I don't know. I can't,
I can't bring myself to watch the band knuckle boxer. I'll tell you what, man,
it changed my opinion. I was thinking for a long time that MMA done correctly,
you'd have bare knuckles because I was like,
why you got bear shins and bear knees and bear elbows,
but you have your knuckles pat it up. That doesn't make any sense.
But now I see how that cuts like Chris Lieben, his face was just opened up,
man. I was like, that is just,
I don't want to see people take unnecessarily cuts that way because then that
scar tissue opens up and then shortens their careers, stops fights.
I don't want to say hey, also breaking hands. I mean like I, I game.
That's why I don't want to watch it. I, I'm not a big fan of cuts.
You remember Marvin Eastman and Vito Belfort and I don't, I don't, I don't like,
I don't like, you know, horrific. I W I,
I want to show you something. Okay. That's like you, you, when you do see,
when you see those gory videos, does that really throw, you know? Okay.
So I'm going to show you something and it's horrible. Right? But um, oh crap.
What is it? Um, it's a video. It's a video of, of,
I don't even know how to explain. I don't want,
I don't want to tell you what it is until you see it,
because it is so graphic. Is it a fight video? It's not a fight video.
It's just something gory. Okay. You want to see some more? Yeah. All right.
Show me. I keep, I'm forgetting how to get through my phone sometimes,
but I found it. Okay. Let's see.
So you're watching that, right?
Okay.
I don't know if those two things go together.
Jesus Christ. Oh, Jesus Christ.
Hmm.
Yeah. Whoa. You can see that JV. Yeah. Yeah.
Whoa. I don't know if that, that part one equals part two.
I Dunno if that was just edited, but still it looks like
took him right in the mug. Oh,
that seems like what it would do if a log hit you in the face like that.
I don't know. This guy's whole head is broken. He's missing his upper jaw. Yeah.
Yikes. Like I don't, I don't want anyone to look at, you know. I know.
How about Cyborg? When Michael Venom page hit him with that knee? Whew.
That's one that makes you, you make shit fucking, your whole body tightens up,
right?
Like how do you, how do you get somebody's skull? No much force.
You have to hit somebody with like that crazy.
Think of all the fights you've seen. We've never seen that. I've seen that.
Think about
this. When something, you've,
everybody's been hit on the head or something fell on your head and it's the
edge of something and it just that pain. Yeah.
I can't imagine what that pain is like. That's, that's bone. The ball.
I don't want to see it. There's like, no, I'm not saying open up.
Just like I looked over there like that. That screen brightened up and, well,
how about yeah, cosmo Alexandra did to save.
That's crazy too. One Punch broke like eight bones in his face.
Yeah, like it's not, this is not for the lighthearted man. Not for the,
I get a lot of people lie like I'm not, I'm not a sage hater,
but I'm not a sage lover. You know what I mean?
But like I don't wish that on anybody. I don't wish that on anybody either.
And I don't, I don't like that matchup. I didn't like that match up at all.
I was like what are they doing? That is a, that's a world champion striker.
Cosmo is a fucking bad man. He's a bad man.
He likes people on fire, you know,
and him at 185 pounds with no weight cutting.
And that's one of the things that he said about that fight.
How good he felt like we didn't have to cut any weight and you see how thick
fucking full he looked.
It wasn't depleted and dehydrated and everything like that.
And that is just not sages. It was bring it back to the beginning, but look out,
look how thick he is to like if you seen Cosmo's fights before.
I remember when he fought John Wayne par in lion fight, I mean,
but John Wayne Pars a multiple time world champion and a skillful guy and he
managed to avoid like the big power shots like this and didn't get hurt.
But it's also cosmo having a chance to punch you with MMA gloves on too with the
majority of his career. He fought all the time. Boom.
I mean that is a crazy punch. Everything's behind that. It's,
and it's like this kid is just not ready for this yet.
He's just not ready for this as much as he has experienced in karate.
And you know, he had some good MMA fights against some, you know, good fighters.
This is not a good fighter. That's an elite world class striker. Right.
And you know, you're fighting him with little gloves on in a ring and you're,
you're mixed martial arts game is primarily a striking. Yup. Yeah.
You had a big disadvantage. Huge, enormous disadvantage.
I like what one is doing though. I really do. I like what they're doing.
I thought that's interesting too that they made them fight in a ring. Well,
I don't know how many events one does in a ring versus does in a cage,
but the dynamics shift radically. When you get caught, you get cornered.
You know, like that's one of the cool things about the Bella tore case.
It's circular. There's no corner and you're on it. Yeah. But that, you know,
when you see a boxing ring like that, the owl that's,
especially again with Cosmo, like, yes, that's where he spent most of his time.
Like all of his time.
It's a different environment and cutting that off is so much easier.
And for a guy who's, who knows how to do that, it's, he,
it's almost like sage was set up. I'm not saying they sent him up.
Can you set up? Yeah. That's just a bad situation. He didn't have, I mean,
I guess he didn't have to take the fight. I don't know how I, I should say,
I don't know how they do their matchmaking. I Dunno if it's like,
like the UFC kind of forces fights on people, right. They let you know, like,
you take this fight or you know, we're probably not gonna call you. Yeah,
I mean it's up to you, but if you want a career in the UFC,
you take fights when you get them.
But like when you see fighters in boxing, they get,
if they have a really good manager, they,
the manager knows who the guy you're going to fight is and says, okay eve,
this guy is good, but you can beat them.
And this is what I like about this style. He's going to,
he's going to challenge you in a couple of areas,
but overall you're a better fighter than than him.
But it'll give you a challenge and we're trying to build your record up to get
you a title shot and you know,
maybe you'd be nine to no 10 to no 11 and no 12 no. And then you know,
you get to a certain level and they go, okay, we're ready to fight for a title.
And then it would be this big promotion, Eve Edwards, you know,
17 and Oh, you know, 16 knockouts and shows your highlight reel.
Like this is something that big management,
this is the reason why it's exists in boxing.
It's actually smart because it's part of the development of a fighter for every
Jon Jones.
They could just step into the octagon at 21 years old and start fucking people
up. There's so many young fighters that could be world champions,
but then they run into elite competition early in their career and get fucked up
and then they, they, their dream kind of drifts away from them.
If fear gets puts in, put it in them early. Yup. Yup. That's a problem.
And unnecessarily in my, in my opinion.
Yeah, I agree. Um, and that's,
that's the thing about guys getting into the UFC really early in their career.
Like that's everybody's goal. Virtually every fighter on the planet,
that's where they want to be. That's the most recognized belt. That's,
that's the belt that everybody considers the highest rank belt. Right.
So that's where everybody wants to get.
And getting there with two or three fights on new, you're right under your belt.
Um, it's exciting, but like you don't, you're in the wolfsten now.
Yeah. It's not smart. Everybody wants to say they're a UFC fighter,
but it really isn't smart.
The smart way to do it is to fight on the regional circuit,
train at a really good gym and develop yourself. Get to a, to Tega. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. I mean there's look, look at Marlin Mariah's.
Did you know when he was before PFL when it was the world series of fighting,
she was fucking everybody up over there and we were watching him going,
how would this guy fair against world-class competition?
And then you get get them into the UFC. Okay, well this guy's the real deal.
He's the real deal. But he,
it took all those years in smaller shows and to build up that sort of skillset
and that confidence and experience is a lot of,
a lot of good guys that came through. They're like gaging sure. Perfect example.
Yeah. And it's also a good
place, um, when you get, when, when guys got bet one,
I'm not talking about now of course, cause it's no longer the world series,
but when guys got, you know,
they got to the UFC and they did their experience show that they weren't ready
for it. And you know, having these smaller promotions,
that's a good thing because some of those guys,
their spirit doesn't necessarily break.
They just know they're not ready for that. Yeah. So yeah,
going back down and working their way back up. But then again, it's hard.
It's sometimes it's hard to, to earn that second shot, you know what I mean?
Yeah.
You can go back and then I guess it all depends also in the relationship you had
with, with, with the powers that be once you, once you're out, you know,
if you went out on a bad note, kind of doesn't really matter. Yeah.
There's some bridge burners out there. Yeah.
Some young guys that get crazy and then they're doing an interview.
Interviews are so toxic, right?
You start getting crazy and you say something that really could fuck up your
entire career and you might not even really mean it. Or if you do mean it,
you might mean it only for an hour, you know? And then after you say like,
why did I say that? Really? I should look at it from their perspective.
They're trying to run a business. Don't be in your feelings.
Don't be in your feelings. Well like you know,
one of the more interesting things about the PFL this season was Vinnie,
my glaze like Vinnie,
my glaze has become who I thought he would be earlier in his career because he's
such a phenom with grappling. I mean he's, he's the legitimate world champion.
I mean, I remember watching him throw a flying armbar unpaid, a Pano,
who's,
I'm a multiple time Brazilian jujitsu world champion himself and Vinny just
locks him up and jumps into a flying armbar. I'm like, that is crazy.
And finished them off. I was like, that is insane.
Like that's how good Vinnie is. And he was catching people and,
and I thought he was on his way. And Sean, what is his last name?
Sean O'Connell. O'Connell. Yeah. I want to say O'Malley, but I know that song.
I'm saying Sean O'Connell. I was very impressed, man.
Amazed that he was able to beat him. Man. He put,
he put a real good game plan together. He had Jeremy who in his corner too. Huh?
I haven't been having that knowledge behind you. You know what I mean?
But I'm like Vinny,
I think his fights lasted like not even around to get into the get to the finals
cause that's four fights and he hasn't even spent five minutes in the cage yet.
You know, and then Sean takes him to the end. But then this season,
Vinnie just fought a couple of weeks ago and um, man, the,
I guess it's kind of like the strategy to be Vinny of course,
is to keep the fight standing. I'm not get taken down and not be on bottom.
Don't even let him pull guard. But he took, he took,
he took a pounding in that first round he needs, he needs a win.
He needs like he needs to show that, that Vinny level Jujitsu,
his next fight to get into the playoffs this year. Did He,
when his fight he lost, he lost, stopped in the second I believe. But who?
Emiliano Saudi. Oh, he lit him up, man.
He just just picked him apart. Stayed on the outside.
I think Vinnie did get land one take down, but Saudi defended guy back to his
feet and he like you just worked him body head, just really good boxing.
Yeah.
If any might be the just that guy that's just elite level Jujitsu guy that never
quite realizes his full potential in MMA, you know?
And it's also like the amount of time you've got to think he was back in the
ultimate fighter. Ryan Bader stopped him in the finals.
That was a long time ago. I was like the third or fourth or fifth season,
something like that. Yeah. So was that 2007 or something like that 12 years ago.
That's a long career.
That's a long time. But like he still looks good. He still has his,
his striking has gotten better. I mean,
he's not going to be able to go toe to toe with the elite level strikers in his
weight class, but um, his wrestling is where we're at.
I think that's where he really needs to focus now. If he still wants to do well,
how much longer he wants to do this. Right. Because, you know,
I think Vinnie's 30, 33 34 35 it was close.
But um, but his striking is you have to respect it.
You have to respect his standing and if he could transition to,
to taking a shot off of that and just chain wrestle,
like that'll be so much better because on top of course, yeah.
You know he's going to be a monster, but if he's pulling guard, um,
there's a few guys he's going to catch. But most, most of the better guys. You,
you're going to have a problem there. What you're saying to his birthday today?
Oh, I'm 35 happy birthday Vinny.
Yeah, he's one of the few guys,
I mean he didn't get like two Camorra's in a row. Two cameras on the same night.
Did it really? Yeah. One for fighting on the same night. That shit's crazy.
I'm not a fan of that. Why?
Because I think that the problem is say if two guys fight right,
and one guy knocks the other guy out real quick and then goes into the next
round, but the other guy who is going to fight, he,
he fights and he has a rough three round war and then he goes into the next
fight.
One guy is super fresh and the other guy's body's beat to shit just doesn't,
doesn't make sense. Like one guy's legs are all fucked up. He's been leg kicked.
He might've got dinged,
he might be like a little dizzy and then he's going to go and fight an hour
later. This seems ridiculous to me
about like, does that, so that's different for you if it's wrestling or if it's,
um, a submission grappling towards yes. Because there's no striking. Yeah,
because, no, strike, the thing about that is you can always,
if you're going in banged up, right, or if you get hurt.
We saw that last year in the playoffs. Um, I forget who they, I believe it was,
um, mom and dad, no Islam. Mom Dove. Right. He won his fight,
but he, I don't remember what the injury was, but he pulled out, you know,
and the guy he beat who was not banged up really,
I mean the fight was a tough fight. Um, he claimed he wasn't,
he was going in at 100%, except for the conditioning. Um,
yeah, but the thing is like,
there's a difference from being injured. Like you tear your ACL and you know it.
And like I can't fight. I can't go on and just being beat shit.
That's, that's, that is the difference. But yeah, I mean,
what's the difference between fight you? You can only fight five rounds, right?
Like,
and no commission is going to let you fight five rounds more than five rounds at
a night. So in the playoffs with the PFL,
we have two rounds in the quarterfinals and in the semifinals is three rounds.
Right. It's kind of tricky because should the fight ended up in a draw,
then the fighter won the first round wins the fight. What? Yeah.
I think it should be the second. Yeah.
Some people think because you'd be the second.
Some people think you should be the first fighter that won the first round.
I don't know. I mean that seems silly. It's,
yeah. So I just want to like if the teacher
comes and pulls you off a dude you're on top of you punch him in the face,
but that guy was hitting you with a jab for the first two minutes.
Doesn't matter. Everybody knows you won the fight street fire rules. Yeah.
You're on top and you punched him in the face when the,
when they break it up you one. Yeah, he knows it too. Everyone knows it.
I agree. So I do like, I do like the second round being weighed,
weighed more heavily. Yeah.
I think also having the second mountain weighed more heavily, um,
where the first round is you're going to press the action and the guy's not
really gonna run. Cause if, I mean, if you do run, you can't be assured that if,
unless you dominated the first round completely,
you can't be assured that you're going to win that.
I get the strategy though, where they want people to fight exciting fights.
They don't want anybody to hold their energy hold back until the second round.
I get that. That makes sense. Yeah.
But at the same time from one guy presses the action in the first,
everybody's going, I mean you got to go. Yeah, that's true. I Dunno,
but it's, it's, see that's the, that the only problem with that is if,
if commissions would allow three rounds, you know. Yeah.
I mean what's an extra round anyway? I like there's, there's not a single,
it's weird how sometimes these people who don't do it and they, they say they,
they um, they're concerned for your safety and you're like, we're fighting.
We already agreed to do this. It's like, yeah,
I mean I know this is the worst thing that could happen today is a fight. Yeah.
You're worried about someone's safety. Yeah. It's funny. It's, I don't know man.
It's,
I just think that twice a night when you talked to neurologists in particular,
they, they think it's very dangerous. Yeah.
Cause they think repeated concussions.
Like one of the things about football they're really concerned with was guys
that get head injuries early in the game. They,
they sit on the bench for a quarter and then jump back in.
They're worried about that.
They're worried about repeated concussions in one day.
I get that. And I also think like, we're football's concern. I again,
I love football.
I still like to watch this sport and I have nothing against that. You,
as long as the, the players have the information, you're making a choice. Right.
This is freedom
now. Today. Yeah. They have the, you know, Bo Jackson,
so he wouldn't let his kids play. Yeah. Well, which is really interesting.
He said that he didn't know. I said no one knew back then.
Yeah. Nobody, I mean it's like, well yeah,
they saw you wearing a helmet, you're going to be fine.
See, that's the thing about,
that's where I think the difference between fighting and,
and the NFL and football happens is because like, if,
if I gave you a basketball and I stood here and I said,
throw that in my head as hard as you can, as hard as you want. Right.
As hard as you can. Right. I don't think you're gonna go,
you're gonna try to smash me in the head with the basketball. Right. Right.
But if I put on a helmet, you,
you're going to be more willing to throw it harder. Right.
But it's like that doesn't, that, that really doesn't change anything is now,
now that you, this perceived, um, defense protection, there's just the barrier,
but I'm still getting that concussive force of you throw that basketball at my
head. Right? Yeah. Well, when you take football, you,
you're not taking just a punch traveling at like 20,
30 miles an hour from like two feet away hitting somebody. Yes. It's repeated.
But like, people don't take me really more than 60 punches in a, in a, in a,
in a fight. But, um, sometimes they do. But, um, football,
there's like you're slamming into each other and we're talking about 250 pound
men at full speeds at 15 to 20 miles an hour. Boom,
boom. You know, and that's, they're both running at each other, but that's,
yeah, like a head on collision. So that's insane. That's, that's so different.
But I'm like, I don't, I don't, I don't say don't, don't play this sport.
Just make sure the information is out there and let that the people make their
choice
is ever going to be anything they can do to figure out how to protect the brain.
And so, I mean,
this gotta be a way that they can figure out how to wow. Maybe not,
I mean your brain sloshing around inside there. Yeah.
All right, good. That they have a way like give us the information,
let you decide where you want to put your brain list or not.
You know what I mean? Yeah.
But like what I like the thing about the PFL because when you get,
when you get to the playoffs that those two fights one night, um,
I fun tournament. I ain't like, you know,
we knew about boxes being punchy and all that. I knew that, but I'm like,
I don't know. There's, there's a thing, there's a thing about competing,
there's a passion about competing and having that tournament opportunity.
That's a lot of fun. Like a lot of these young guys love these young fighters.
They didn't get the chance to fight in tournament's because tournament's kind of
ended recently, you know, um, the pride tournament's were awesome.
And then of course back then it was a lot of points that UFC had the tournament
originally. So that's a whole lot of fun. But like with the PFL season,
what I like about it is,
is there's a bunch of different storylines that happens. You know, you, you,
you're fighting to gain points to get into the playoffs.
So the f there are two regular season fights and the first regular season fight
you, um, you, you know, where everybody stayed in at zero,
but then you come in the second. Of course everybody wants to win their fight.
Everybody wants to win as soon as possible to get the maximum amount of points.
But then when you come into the second fight, then everybody's like, okay,
you're looking at the numbers. I need this, I need this. You're concerned.
Then you're watching throughout the night to figure out who's,
who's got to do what.
I you explain that to people that don't understand what we're talking about
because there's a, you guys have a score system. We have a scoring system.
So the professional fighters league, um, a win win,
you have to win. You have to, we have a seeding for the playoffs.
So the top eight fighters in, in the,
in the melee classes and the women are only eight.
So the top four fighters get into the playoffs, right?
And you get in by point standings. So you get a draw.
That's one point for each fighter. You get a win. That's three points.
But you gotta win by stoppage in the third round.
That's four points when by stoppage in the second five win by stoppage in the
first six. So you try to accrue points.
So accumulate points so that when we get to the playoffs,
you're seated in the top eight and I'm talking about the men.
Just remember that the women are our four in the playoffs.
But when you get seated for the top eight and then you fight the quarter final
and semifinal fight on the same night and the winners from those nights,
the windows in the semifinals go to the championships and that's on New Year's
eve and that's for $1 million. So you get three fights for $1 million. Right?
Um, that's pretty fucking good. That's really good. Right?
So I wish this tournament was around when I was like,
I'm like, yeah, I want to do that, you know? Sure. I want to win $1 million.
So how many fighters got a million? I'm six. Wow.
Six fighters got $1 million last year. So, um, there it is. Six champions.
Million dollars each. Yeah. And this year will be six, six millionaires again,
um, the, the way that the season plays out, like I said, you,
you fight the first round of the regular season when you come in.
We're going into the second round of the regular season now. So on,
on the eighth. On July eight, I'm sorry, July 11th,
on Thursday night we're going to be in Atlantic city.
We have the women and we have the women hundred and 55 pounders and then we had
the man welterweights and so this is a fight that I'm really excited about,
right? Maggie and Maggie, mad caramel, he won last season,
but then Chris Curtis came into the PFL and he won his first fight.
Maggie had won his first fight, got six points. Chris Curtis gets four points,
got third brown stoppage and he called out McNamara carom off you call out the
champion from last year.
So he wants to go into this next fight finding the champion. I'm like,
why would you do that? Because if you lose that,
you're not making it into the playoffs,
you lose your opportunity to million dollars. But like that, that, that,
that provato of being a fighter and wanting, you know, you want to,
you want to knock the best guy off, right? You always want the best guy.
But to call him out in a fashion where, where it threatened your potato,
like he has to perform, he has to perform now.
So like that fight really interests me because Maggie Mag Karamazov is really
good. He can do everything. Like he's one of those guys who does it look like,
you know his body type. He doesn't look like the kind of guy who will smash you,
but he will like, did you see Ray Cooper last year?
Like Ray Booper the second ray Cooper the second.
That's what's crazy is a Jake shields Fahd his dad and him and him and fought
him twice. Dow was what was kind of fucked up. I watched both those fights.
I was like, damn, they're making Jake shields fight this dude again.
They didn't make him do it. I know they didn't make them do it,
but he fucked Jacob and then he fucked him up again a couple months later. Yeah.
How many months later? Was it like three or four months? Yeah. That's rough.
But a a k a bad kao like that from the same guy. And then you find to be,
I mean he didn't have any answers for that dude.
I like to fight a guy like ray who was a,
I believe it was state champion Hawaiian wrestler. Right?
And Ou does he have some fucking heavy hands?
He's like the Mike Tyson of like welterweight
and for Walter Wade, he's fairly short. He's like five, seven. Yup.
He just throws fucking bricks. Well, sodas, John Howard though.
John Howard's got some fucking bombs in his hands. Yeah, I liked that fight too.
Yeah. Very interesting fight. Yeah.
That's a very good fight. Now with that fight,
I [inaudible] because ray hits Hawaii.
John Howard does have some bombs in his hand. I think. Um,
ray has more power though. You know,
I feel like how it's going to have to stick and move,
use those leg kicks and try to slow them down. You, you, you can't,
you can't go out there trying to take ray Cooper out early.
Well, John's been around a long time to John. John is set a long career. Yeah.
You know, I mean, how old is John Now? I think John is probably like 33 now.
He's at least five. He was in the UFC a long time ago,
minus 36 oh six. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And he's been in some crazy wars.
You know,
he's been in some wars. He's black. He like, he's,
he just got his black belt and that's [inaudible] the only guy who beat ray
Cooper last season. You know, American made Caramel, beat beating my submission.
Um, I think that's, that's the best,
the best option for a lot of guys facing him cause he has so much power.
Now all of these are on NBC sports. Is that what they're doing? Yes. PN Two.
ESPN two ESPN and ESPN plus. Oh okay. Well that's, that's right. That's,
that's new to this year. Right. That's new to this year. That's very exciting.
That's very exciting.
So ESPN plus w which also has the EOC and put it on ESPN as well.
That's great. Yeah. That's so good man.
That ESPN is stepping into MMA like this. I love it.
It's huge because I thought this last year when the UFC signed with ESPN,
I was like, like that's a great thing because a lot of times the UFC,
when fight fans watch the UFC, they only, they only think of the UFC as,
as mixed martial arts. I'm sorry. They think of mixed martial arts as the UFC.
Right. You know, people ask you, you train UFC, you know. Right, right, right,
right. But um, but like ESPN being the worldwide leader in sports,
I've seen like highlights on ESPN from rise in from, you know, from Japan,
from one while he's different from, from some small promotions.
And it's like that helps the sport grow,
that helps people recognize that this is just,
there's not only one avenue for the sport and these,
these guys do have to cut their teeth somewhere.
And also there are some other organizations where where you can get some quality
fights and really good fighters. Um, and then money and money. Yeah.
Like I like there being a lot more options for guys where the money's concerned.
I'm very
happy about that.
I mean that's how they lured sage over to one FC and also Eddie Alvarez and
mighty mouse, you know? Yeah.
But it's a different world when there's no way cutting, you know,
I am just such a giant fan of that know what weight cutting deal the way they're
doing it over at one FC.
It's okay. So what exactly are they doing? You, you, you hydration tests.
And how, how's how far out before the fight?
I don't know. I don't know how they're doing it, but it says, wait,
what was explained to me is they essentially say if you are the 170 pound
champion, they bump you up to like one 85 yep. They're like, look,
you're going to fight one 85 now there's no way cutting.
We are going to test you. We're going to test your way.
We're going to test your hydration. We're gonna,
we're gonna know what your real weight is. So this is your real weight.
Your real weight as 185 pounds,
you're dropping 15 pounds of water to get to one 70 but we both know that when
you get into that octagon, you're going to be 185 pounds.
So let's just cut the shit and have you never dropped down to 170 and just say
you're 185 pound fighter, which is what they are.
I mean stand next to guys like Kamara loose mon. You're like,
how are you one 70 that doesn't make any sense or are yo well,
who's the craziest version? Yo well is so big. He's so big.
His fucking neck starts at the top of his head and his, his shoulders,
they may meet the traps in the middle, you know, it's like [inaudible].
He's just as mammoth of a man and the idea that that guy is 185 pounds is
bananas.
I remember Tim t bow, those, those kinds of guys. Yeah.
And these guys are still muscular the entire time. I don't know how glaze. Yeah.
Did it all those years.
Glieson was walking around well over one 90 and getting down to one.
Not even man, like I'd see t bow in the gym and has like tee ball.
What do you weigh right now? He's like, oh my friend.
One one 91 95 like get on the scale. No, no, no.
He's not doing that, you know,
easy like two oh five to 10 really two oh five to 10 you would get down to one
55 so big. How did he do it? I don't know.
Sheer force of will. Yeah. So I've, I've seen him,
I weighed cuts just like laid out. Like we,
we fought on a couple of cars together also, you know,
and he just like laid out and Ila, he has to be carried out of the room,
you know? Oh, of course you have to walk up to the scale on your own. But um,
that's so insane that you let a guy do that and then they fight a day later,
then yeah. The next day like, but you wouldn't,
you wouldn't let somebody recover from the flu, like say, Oh, I feel better.
The temperatures down. You want to let them fight the next day. Right. You know,
they probably be healthier. Yeah. Much healthier. I don't know. It's a,
it's the dumbest thing in all combat sports in terms of, okay. Yeah,
but I can be avoided. So you think the one, there's no,
I can't, I'm, because I haven't been in the position,
I don't know how you work the system with the one FC system.
I would like to talk, talk
to Chaudhry Cha tree. Cha Tree is the one who set it all. I mean that's,
it's his organization and he, I think he's the leader in terms of the safety.
And it also fairness because I think weight cutting is, I mean, look,
everybody's doing it so it's not like everybody is ethically compromised,
but I think it's cheating. I think it's legal cheating.
That's what I think it is. If you're pretending you weigh 125 pounds,
like mighty mouse does,
he doesn't really weight one 25 he weighs like one 41 40 something, you know?
That's what he really weighs. And the thing is,
when he's fighting over in one FC, those are the guys he's actually fighting.
He's fighting guys his size. Yeah.
So the guys that really did a great job of cutting weight,
they do have a significant advantage once they get into that octagon.
But I don't think that's a fair advantage.
There's some guys that do it really well too. Yeah. Really well.
Some guys are excellent at it. Yeah. Some guy, I'm Joelle. He's excellent.
Even though he's missed a couple of times though, some of those guys, they just,
the advantage is so spectacular. How does James Vick, may one 55.
That's a good point. He's a tall fella. Yeah. Yeah. There's a lot of those guys.
How Paul felter, Paul Valdez and fucking gorilla. How's he going?
Tell them what 55 he so thick. Yeah. Yeah, he's broad man.
I remember when Dustin was making one 45 [inaudible] crazy.
He looks like he's having a hard time making 55 now. But look man,
the difference between him at 45 and 55 it's pretty easy.
I'll never forget. So with Dustin,
like I, I'm, I'm kind of biased cause he's one of my best friends. Right?
But um,
you see how Max Max dominated a lot of guys at 45. Um,
and then the, all the, you know, you talk about Max is like now he,
now he's the greatest. Now he's the greatest at one 45 he may,
he may be the goat. He may be greater than Josie Aldo.
Like that's an argument that people can make.
Well, you beat him twice, right? Although he'd beat him later in his career.
Right. Josie is not 50 years old. He was in his early thirties.
Yeah. And he was still, he was still the number one guy.
He was still dominating everybody else. Yup. Right.
And he kept beating everybody else in corner. Um,
but like the way Max beat those guys, beat Ortega,
beat Joe say twice. Um, and then Dustin's having these tough fights. He's, he's,
he's fighting these same guys. He's fighting games. He's fighting Eddie. Um,
he's, he's winning them along. He's convincingly winning them. But um,
when he fights Max, like Max the,
the fight is Dustin's fight as the same fight that he had with gay.
Jesus ain't as far as competitiveness. Right. Max was still in there,
but Dustin Wednesday's, but like, I just like, this is where my bias kicks in.
I'm like, give that man some credit, man. Like, I mean,
I know everybody loves us. I mean, not everybody, but people love Dustin.
They appreciate the way he fights. They appreciate his style, but I'm like, man,
he's, he's taken out like champions taken out champions gates.
You as a champion who was in world series, but he's a champion. Yeah.
To got Eddie champion. Yup. You know, Max champion and he's like all these guys,
he's beaten Sergio pet, I mean Andrea Anthony Pettis champion, you know,
just champion after champion rises to the occasion.
He fought better against Max and any other fighter you ever fought in his
career.
That's the thing about him though. Like he just, these, he's like,
he's like the cream, you know, he's easy rises that that's, that's, that's why,
that's why his nickname's and diamond, you know,
what do you think happens when he fights? Could be, yeah.
This, this is the one that's the fight. Like, so fight, like that's, I mean,
could be, he was, the guy. Could be, was definitely the guy. And um,
I was talking to him about it. I, so I'm s I started a new podcast. I um,
I it's called yes. Sup Fan.
Subfamily sub fan with Eve Edwards. Yeah, I know.
I just just released it today. It's a on, on, um, on my youtube.
I just started today. Yeah, well just released the first episode. Oh, all right.
Um, and Dustin's my first guest. Oh, perfect.
So I was out there with him last week and we just hanging out and we talked
about some of that. But like,
what do I think happens? This is a tough fight.
This like it's the toughest fight everybody's going to get. Right. Um,
I absolutely understand and agree that can be,
you should be going in as the favorite, right? Um, I want,
of course I want Dustin to win this fight. The every round starts on the feet.
Dustin's got to make smart moves every single time because when [inaudible]
takes him down, it's,
it's almost virtually impossible to get back to your feet. Right?
Um, and that's where it could be. He was going to want this fight to happen. Um,
Dustin's going to have his opportunities, but like,
is he going to be able to stop that wrestling consistently enough to make this
fight happen where it's best for him? And that's the hardest thing.
He's got a good training camp. He's got really good people there with him.
He's got Mike Brown there. You know who I want to get with him,
Greg or Gillespie. I want Greg Gillespie to, to,
to get with Dustin and just get on top of him for the next two months.
It's just feel that high level wrestling, smashing pressure, that pressure,
pressure pressure and get comfortable working out of it. Working on two there,
protecting yourself, doing that. Would he be interested in,
I mean he might fight him down the road though. It's possible. Yeah. Right. Um,
but like Tyron and Robbie trained together a long time ago. Oh that's true.
Yeah. I mean that's how you get better.
Yeah. Like it's, it's, it's one of those things where it's like you,
you gotta sometimes you gotta trade with a potential arrival or you know,
not an enemy, but, um, but like the iron sharpens iron.
Yup. No, and sometimes you gotta you have to go with somebody that's,
we'll match up in the future. It just,
specially if you're going to fight a guy who has that same style,
and I think you nailed it too,
cause Greg or Gillespie is probably when you get past,
could be the scariest wrestler in the division. Yeah. I mean,
he's a guy that gets on top of people and just smashes them and he's relentless
with his, with his wrestling also. He's a guy who's not going to get tired.
He's going to put that pressure on you is going to come forward
and once he gets a hold of you,
if you don't use perfect technique to escape and get that distance back,
he's just going to chain wrestle and chain wrestle. There's, there's no,
there's no stopping until you're doubt. Until he scores his two there,
there's the, the take down is still happening.
He's got some fucking relentless strength and conditioning sessions too that he
puts on his Instagram. You watch it and you go, oh,
this is why this guy doesn't get tired.
Fuck that guy doesn't get tired cause he's, he's obsessed.
Like he, he runs, he wants like five minutes miles. Does he really like,
he'll run like six of them straight. Like he like he will,
he will run like you'll run eight miles and you'll keep the ball on the six
minutes. So he'll run six miles and a half an hour. Yeah, he can do that.
Fuck. He's crazy. Well that's crazy. That's crazy.
High level marathon pace, right? Yeah. Like period. People don't,
people don't know some of the things about, about these guys. Like,
like there was a point where training with these guys, I was just like,
alright man, I'm too old to be doing that. Like I can't,
I just can't keep up with that. You know what I mean? And that was one of them,
man Gregor, like we were on this Nike running app together and I'm like,
I had to delete him off my thing cause I was a kid,
like discuss like I'm not trying to beat that, you know?
That's hilarious. Like for real, you should go fishing with them.
I want to go fishing with that dude. I want to take up fishing in The Bahamas.
Oh that's a good spy. Yeah. And line fishing. Not,
not like that with the rod weight. We fish a lot of line fishing. Okay.
Just with your hands. Yeah. And um,
that's why when you feel the fish on the line, oh,
and you're just fighting and pulling. Uh, I love that. It's funny. I mean there,
there are some fish, like I'm not pulling up a group of like that, you know?
Why do you, why do you prefer line fishing with your hands?
Just because it's the old school way. Just, just because it's the way I grew up.
Um, like when we, when we get like my cousin I told you about who's we,
you know, free dives, like he'll spearfish.
So I remember once I was a little kid and um, he was out with,
his daddy was spear fishing and he missed the fish and he smashed the turtle.
Oh, I thought you was going to say his hand. No, no. He's silly. See,
somebody hit the, his spirit. A turtle turtle took off with the spirit. Oh No.
So yeah, I mean it's potentially some turtle out there in the ocean right now.
The spirit stuck in them. This is like 30 years ago.
Those things live for him to live forever.
Wonder if it's survived the calcified over the, the spear point. Yeah.
I never been spearfishing, but it looks like a hell of a lot of fun. I have,
I've never spearfished like inside the, I've, you know,
I played with him on land. Um, and of course it's with the, with the, with the,
what's that? The rubber, you know, like kind of like a slingshot. Yeah.
The bungee cord. So that one was cool, but um, of course they have the guns.
I would like to use a spear gun, but I like, um, I dunno,
you gotta kind of have to earn that, right? I feel like, yeah,
I gotta I got to go free diving with curly and do some of that.
As long as you think you can hold your breath under water. Um,
so we used to have this thing as a kid where I was,
where we'd say we tried to blow the pool and, um, I, I can,
I can swim in Olympic level. Well,
I have swam Olympic length pool staying under water. Right.
But how long does that take? That probably took me like, Nah,
I probably took me like 40, 45 seconds.
And then also you're swimming. Yeah, you're exerting. So yeah. But, um,
but like he, like I'm telling you,
he goes down and he's under the water for easily three minutes. You know,
it was supposed to be insane at that. It's Eagan, Eagan. Anyway,
I heard about that. I already heard about six minutes. Seven minutes.
Yeah. I, it's like, I don't know, maybe from sucking up a joke.
Yeah, I think it's just practice.
And then you just practice free diamond and Hawaiians,
they do that crazy workout. There was a member,
one of the countdown shows and BJ was supposed to be fighting George Saint
Pierre.
They had him doing his strength and conditioning in the water where he would
dive under water and pick up a rock and,
and move it and drop it and swim to the surface and drive,
dive down again and pick up the rocks like a big ass rock and move it.
And that was part of his strength conditioning.
So like, um, the, the, I,
I was D I was good with my cardio ties on a guest, but, um,
like when punches are coming at you, a lot of people blink.
A lot of people do that. So that like, that was my thing.
I keep my eyes open a long time, you know what I mean? So that, that's my,
that whole steer camp thing and that kind of comes from that.
I just keep my eyes open, not blinking. Um, those guys who,
who do those underwater things, how do, how do you think that relates to, like,
I understand you can hold your breath longer,
but how do you think that relates to cardio? Because you're not,
you're your muscles not working except to, to hold the rock.
Well, the idea is the doing the rock thing, like loot,
moving and carrying the rock while you're underwater. I don't know, man.
I don't know enough about it, but I know I had layer in Hamilton on recently,
you know, he's a big time surfer and a,
one of the things that he's doing now with,
he has this whole program where they're doing weights in the water. So they're,
they're doing like heavy dumbbells and they'll,
they'll bring them to the bottom of the water and uh,
you have to take the dumbbell swim with it to the top,
catch your breath of air and then you go back down again. And there's,
there's also doing some where they're taking like a, you know,
like a 70 pound dumbbell.
You hold it to your chest and you're swimming through the water while you're
trying to carry this dumbbell and you know, it's extremely difficult to do.
The thing is how much is that applicable to fight it?
That's what I don't know.
Cause I remember when I was like real heavily in did you do to at one point in
time I didn't do any striking for like, like a whole year.
I didn't even hit pads and then, but I was in really good. You did too shape.
I was rolling a lot and then I went to hit pads. I was like, God damn it.
Why am I gassing out so quick? This is crazy. It's a different shape, right?
Yeah, it's different shape.
I don't, I always, I'm always concerned about that.
Are curious about that anyway
because, because of all those different aspects of it, um,
you know, there, there are times when when you,
when you're grabbing on to something,
holding onto something and you eat it and then you get back to your feet and all
that lactic acid builds up in your arms and your arms are slow,
but like you still feel your conditioning feels good but you just feel heavy.
But I'm there. There's those times also when you're,
you're grappling and then you get back to your feet and then it's like your arms
don't feel tired, but it's like, it feels it's a d. I don't know. I don't,
is it because you're holding your breath and maybe that's what going on the
waters for, I don't know. You know, the people that,
the train BJ for in the prime of his career was a Marlboro Penivich.
Do you remember that? Yeah, I remember that name. They, they,
they had these ridiculous plyometric drills they had them doing and their
attitude and nick curse on is one of their proteges and he still sort of has the
same philosophy. Their attitude is that you already know how to fight.
Like you're already a skillful fighter when you get to the UFC.
If you have eight weeks to get ready for a fight or 12 weeks,
get ready for a fight,
the most important thing is your gas tank and that you should concentrate on
these fucking preposterous plyometric drills and strength and conditioning
drills and just get your body so you have the biggest fucking gas tank possible
and then all your skills you just drill like that shouldn't have any,
any effect like cardio wise,
like if you're doing drills as far as like striking, grappling,
combination drills or whatever you're doing,
like those things should almost be secondary to strength and conditioning.
That's their attitude. I kind of agree with that.
I mean there's a point where yeah,
you can always improve technique-wise but are you going to do that in a eight
week camp? Right, right. Like you do that,
you do that in your downtime right now. You do that when you're not in camp.
When camp comes, it's all about being ready to fight for as long as you need to.
As hard as you can.
And I think their attitude also is that this way you're doing way less barring
way less opportunity to get hurt.
And mostly it's these crazy plyo drills,
box jumps and all this crazy shit, medicine ball stuff, all this,
all this stuff where you just explode, expose, expose folks.
Well everything is just go, go, go, go, go.
So that your body's just used to that. So then when you get into a fight,
your body has this insane gas tank and they might,
I mean there's something to it, cause those were BJ's best days.
The Sean sherk fight, the Diego Sanchez fight.
That was Prime BJ Penn when he was the motherfucker of motherfuckers.
That was what was up. I mean he was,
he was training with the Marinovich is did you,
did you see that video of him beating of the bounce? Everything. Sad,
sad. They still obviously having a real tough time, man, I didn't,
I just saw the video. I don't know how it happened. I don't know what, yeah,
he's just inside control with flip flops on a, but here's my thing.
I don't know the situation that led to it.
I only saw that he's on top of the guy and I'm like, I'm like this isn't Hawaii.
Like who picks a fight with BJ Penn in Hawaii or who even like steps to BJ pet
in Hawaii. I mean I understand if, if, if there was, I don't know the situation.
If it's like DJ, you've got to leave and he's not listening.
You try to get BJ's friends to come.
They talk to your Garmin and get them out of here. Right. But like you don't,
you don't go toe to toe with BJ Penn. Right. Seems stupid.
It's just a bad choice. I don't care that hey did Max Holloway,
is he the one who started the bottle cap challenge? Do we know that for a fact?
I use the first one I saw.
I'm so tired of seeing people kick bottle caps.
I was going to say there's not some different about his.
Is that the cap state on the bottle? Everyone else is just kicking the cap off.
I kept it on. They kept spinning coincidentally. I know,
but that might be to the bottle of Tito's. I think that he used.
But like that's a little more impressive than some of the other people just
knocking it off or slightly slightly. But it's not that big of a deal.
[inaudible] is a reason why so many people are doing it. It's not that hard.
It's just not that hard. He throw wheel kick like this.
He just like get someone to hold it,
get someone to hold it tight and the wheel kick goes like this and you have the
bottle cap barely on.
So the bottle cap is like this and you just make sure you throw a wheel kick
like that but you don't knock it off. That's everyone else knocked it off.
He kept it on. People use him both water bottle caps,
which have a shallow set of grooves.
Whereas like the bottle that he used has a deeper group.
Would it be more impressive if they showed the whole bottle and that there's not
someone holding it and you like you only? I think
so. Is it anything? Yes. Really. It's,
I've never even thought once about doing it,
so I know how to throw a wheel kick. I'm not going to do it. It's just,
it seems silly to me. Like with Jason Stayed, them's do it.
And when John Mayer did it, the fucking shark was jumped.
Oh, that's [inaudible] wasn't it? That assassin,
I think Max called him out on it. He did it. Yeah. He called out John Mayer.
Why? It's like, why does Justin Bieber want to fight Tom Cruise?
There's so many questions. I would watch it. I would watch it and watch it.
I think Tom Cruise will lock him up with all those crazy voodoo super powers
that he has got from Scientology and the aliens belief in himself, man.
The fights last weekend. Yeah, right. I just, I, so I didn't want to watch him.
I was, um, I was in Texas and, and I called,
there's this ice cream and they were in Austin. I was like, they never have it.
And they had at one time I was, I drove from Houston,
Austin and get some ice cream. You drove from Houston to Austin.
That's like three hours. You drove three hours for ice cream. I did.
Oh my God. You're embracing the fatness.
It was worth it. I know. But you make it by your weight.
You get ready to, for people to see you in the later stage. James, Tony Career,
remember? Yup. I don't want to beat James. Tony.
I want to still be able to take off my shirt. But man,
I had to go get it but wow.
But I did watch the fight and I watched the main card. Frances.
It's fucking terrifying. Right? He's fucking terrifying.
Like when when jds mist.
Yeah. Like you can't,
you can't make mistakes against him cause you take one and that could be it.
Well I felt like jds was doing pretty good in the beginning with the leg kick.
That's what you need to do with Francis.
You need just to keep moving and kick those legs. Yeah.
It'd be interesting to see if, uh,
well I mean obviously Allister was the most elite Stryker's for the most
decorated striker in the whole division and one of the most decorated strikers
ever. And Francis Still Nuke Tim.
He's nukes guys to do is hit you man. Crazy.
You saw 'em um, I can't say his last name. Champion dollar,
his nickname. He fought on the, on the card.
I think he was Cameroonian also.
I didn't see the undercard the only thing I saw was the a Frances fight.
This guy looks like if you take Tyron Woodley and made him bigger,
stronger, faster. What, what's his name?
Dollar Lou Louis Ambu. I can't, I don't know his last name.
I can't pronounce it. But um, as he a new, uh, acquiring,
I think this was his debut. Oh. And he looked,
I honestly, I would like to see him in Alonzo manifold at some point. Um,
they, they both look, they're both like,
it would be like watching like two GI Joe figures, you know,
like just like getting in there and go into town. You know,
that heavyweight that fights in one FC, they call him the panther.
He just did the bottle cap challenge two.
He did like a hook kick and then a wheel kick with a different leg. No, he uh,
he's this dude who is another one of those preposterous looking fellows that
just unbelievably jacked and the heavyweight. What do you, okay, here it is.
We're gonna see the, this is the highlight. Oh yeah.
Oh my God. He's fast. Yeah, I see what you're saying.
And you're just so big and powerful. Heavyweight, whatever way right here.
Oh yeah. Oh, that's, well,
that's interesting because this fucking weight clause needs some new blood,
that's for sure. I mean, Yup, that's a wrap quick. Damn.
I'm like, I'm like, dude, I'm like, man, you want to come make $1 million?
How many contracts? I mean, these contracts,
how many fights did they put them under? Um, you just for the year.
So I continue to get to the main, it's firefights and if you win,
do you have to stay in the PFL? You do not have to. Um,
I don't actually, when it comes to the, I don't know the details on champions,
but I know that the semifinalist, um, have returned.
So I haven't read everyone's contract or anyone's contract really.
But I'm thinking that the semifinals should turn.
I don't know if there is a right to first refusal in the contract for the
season, but, um, that's a good question. I need to know that too.
Like the whole point scoring format thing.
Do you think just it's a good added element? I like it. Um,
I like it and not necessarily because it changes how people's fight people fight
, uh, fighting in this organization that I believe you kind of, you're,
you're a little more loose, you know what I mean? You show up and you know,
you have to, when you try to win and you try to win,
you don't just try to get the w, you know, there, there,
there's a lot of fights sometimes when it's like you're on the bubble and it's
like you're fighting very cautious, you know? Um,
I feel like with this rule set, you get to just be yourself out there.
You every, you always want to win, so you always going to fight to win,
but you don't necessarily change your style to, to play again, play the rules.
You know, you just, you just gotta fight the way you fight.
The only thing that concerns me is the, that's a little complicated.
Paying attention to all the, for the fans, the points and all that.
So I understand why you would say that,
but if you're watching the broadcast, like, you know, you got me Shawn, Randy,
I'm behind the desk and we're,
we're trying to keep people updated with the points and, and how that works.
And, and it's, it's really not that hard. Who? Sean Charlotte call. Oh,
so he's doing commentary. So he's doing commentary Radio Guy, right? Yeah.
He was a radio guy for on, on serious, like a sports radio guy. And He,
I think he still has that program. Yeah. Good for him. Yeah.
He's always a millionaire. Divert that.
He's a millionaire and he's diversified his portfolio and he retired.
He retired from fighting. Um, and now he's in the booth and he's,
I think he's a pretty good play by play guy. Especially as a,
as a former fighter. Not a lot of play by play guys. A form of flighters. Yeah,
that's right. It's usually color. And he, um, he fought well in the UFC too.
He's a tough guy. Yeah, I mean, and, and it's weird. I always make fun of him.
I always tell him like, you fight like homer Simpson,
but your fight IQ is higher. I said fight,
it's like a homer sim cause he takes so many shots, man,
he just like stands in front of you and just trades punches. But like,
like he had to use his brain to be Vinny. You know what I mean? There's a,
Vinny takes you down and gets on top. He's,
he's gonna Grind and grant himself do submission. But I'm with Shawn. He was,
he was, you know, he backed away from, from the,
cause all of his other fights all season were where the homer Simpson fight.
You know, like he got hit sometimes,
but he just came back and bombed on you and, and knocked everybody out.
He lost every first round that he fought. Um, one of them,
he lost the entire fight. But, um, every other fight that he fought,
he lost the first round and then came back and, and just, just bond on guys. Um,
even with any, he lost the first round, you know, but um,
but as far as the points go with that,
you have us communicating how the points work and it,
I remember being in your position before the season started thinking, oh,
the points thing is it's going to be weird. It's going to throw people off,
but legit, you see that play out one time. It's like, oh this is simple.
It makes sense. You know,
you started watching guys like so this next round of fights coming up on the
11th and on the 25th, then August 8th, we have the different weight,
two weight per show. Right. And um,
so we started with the women's lightweights and the welterweights.
Then we have the featherweights and the men's lightweights and then we have the
light hair using the heavies. So on those dates. But when, um,
when you think about the points, right,
you understand that like these guys are on the bubble, you're watching it like,
like the NFL playoffs. When, when, you know,
the last two weeks of the playoffs is like, this guy needs to beat this guy,
but this guy has to finish before this time. You know,
if he can get this win in the second round in less than two and a half minutes,
then he's in the playoffs. But if it goes past two and a half, he's out.
But like we're, we're communicating that to each fight, especially in the,
this second round of the regular season. But I'm,
you want you watching that because these guys know that also, you know, so,
so some, some of that, like it's weird because in,
in a fight you're not thinking about anything else but the guy in front of you.
But you go in there with that mentality that's already on the board.
You don't have it. There's a pin in that. You know,
you don't have to think about it consciously,
but it's in your subconscious at some point. You, you played to that. Um,
but even if you get out of that, if you get beyond that, then you're still this,
there's the pride thing.
And this is a format that didn't exist with the peer fell or no other,
no, this is a new format. This is a new format. They changed the name,
they changed the name,
they changed the name just before they introduced this format. But um,
I believe that the name has changed going into this format.
I think they had one event as the professional fighters league without this
seasonal format. Um, Oh man, I might be too old school. You might be too awful.
But if you, you say that like you gotta try it. Like you, you're a fight fat.
Like I promise you as a fight fan, you're going to appreciate it. Okay.
Tell me what car to watch. What's, what's a good upcoming card?
The next card is a real one because cause the, besides the women, um,
you got Kayla Harrison judo two time when she's a baby. She's right.
She's a baby. She's a beast. But she,
she needs to get a finish to guarantee yourself a playoff spot because she
fought her last fight. She fought her tough,
his opponent who took her to her decision, she, she won the fight convincingly,
but she couldn't get herself a stoppage. Sarah Kaufman is, um, it's,
cause I call from a sitting at the top of the women's rankings, the,
with the finish. Um, there are some, some, some really good women out there too.
They're, he's two kickboxers. They fought each other last time. Bobby,
Joe DL and Jenna Fabian. They're both built like European kickboxers.
They're tall, lanky, long women and they're legit. Good.
Kickboxers they went until they went toe to toe with each other. Um,
they're fighting in this week then not fighting each other,
but they're fighting. They, Jenna Fabian needs a w to get into the playoffs.
So those fights are good.
And then of course we have the welterweights we're talking about Maggie Med,
Megan Med, Karimov and, and, and, um, Chris Curtis.
I don't know if you know Chris Curtis. He, he was on, he was on, um, he was,
I think he was LFA champion or RFA champion and he was on,
he was on the contenders. He won his fighting contenders.
I don't know why he didn't get a contract, but, um, he's really, really,
he's one of those guys
he's been training with, with um, Henderson and those guys for a long time.
Now he's in Vegas with, um, with,
with extreme couture there and then the John Howard Ray Cooper fight.
That's like as a fight fan, you, I know you, you appreciate that.
Excellent Front. So when is that? That is on July 11th. That's next Thursday.
And on ESPN too. Okay. And plus beautiful. Yeah, I'm around.
I'm gonna Watch that Fart. I'm legit.
When we sit down for the broadcast, I'm texting you. Okay. You got it.
If you don't, if you don't respond and put you on blast,
I'll text you back and say, man, this guy doesn't like on ESPN. Plus we are,
we are on ESPN plus and Joe Rogue is nowhere to be found. Oh,
I can't have that happen. I'll be paying attention. All right. Um, so that's a,
so all the fights are going to be on ESPN plus sometimes one ESPN, two fights.
You can't get them on ESPN plus unless you have it set up. Okay.
So a lot of times, so we bounced between ESPN plus him too.
I don't know the format for the first fight.
I can't remember which section of the card is on ESPN two and then on plus,
oh there it is.
So where I'm plus at five 30 to eight 30 east coast time and then on to from
eight 30 to 10 30. That's a great thing about ESPN,
including with the UFC is that so many sports fans just have ESPN on automatic.
Absolutely. Like I was at a pool hall on Saturday night.
I did a show in Baltimore and then we went to a pool hall.
We got there right when junior was entering into the octagon. It was perfect.
It was perfect timing. And I was like,
don't blink because this fucking probably ain't gonna make it out of the first
round. Yeah, that was,
that was a fight I was telling my grandmother about that flight, man. Like, no,
I'm not. I'm not bullshitting you. She was up. It's interesting.
Like Francis wants another shot at the title and you know it's, it's a,
I mean, I don't know why they wouldn't give them another shot at the toe.
In my opinion. It's like what you got now is steep a versus DC that,
that irons out. Who's the champ. Right.
And thank God they made that fight instead of the Brock Loeser fight. I mean,
I think the Brock Lester fight would've been fun. And I want, I love DC.
I want them to get paid. I think he sends Brock Lesnar into another dimension.
That's what I think happens in that fight.
And I think he gets a big payday and that's all great.
But the reality is the real fights, DBAs, DBAs,
the most successful UFC heavyweight champion of all time,
the only guy to ever defend the title four times.
And the only guy that survived the fucking hurricane that is Francis and Ghana.
Yeah, the only guy he figured it out, he figured it out.
It just weather the storm, you know, just roll with the punches, kick the legs,
Jab, move, use your wrestling rassle immediately. But he had to stop.
He had to avoid the punches at first. Yeah. And he's got, you know,
that was an interesting thing too.
I was thinking the fight with steep a with a Francis.
How much did that take out as t pay? Because even though he won that fight,
when DC knocked him out with one punch, like wow, that's crazy.
You don't see Steve Bay
getting knocked out like that.
I wonder if he was still suffering from the in Ghana fight,
which is only like a few months before that.
I don't know if he was still suffering from that versus um,
it's perfect punch to that's, that's the thing. Um, and DC talked about it.
He talked about we saw this being an option in this fight,
this being an opportunity to get this to, to land this shot this and um,
he did it, you know, that, that's the thing. Um, if Francis, anybody,
probably anybody with any power, of course a Francis lands at shots,
nighttime light out also. But, um, he didn't see it or, and he didn't,
he didn't have the skillset to provide that opportunity right there, you know?
So I think, I think that's,
that that might be more telling this sorts of perfect punch to him. You know,
he, he gets rid of the arm on the left side, then boom,
the right hand comes over. You got like that,
that kind of thing that makes me appreciate like fight IQ of a guy like cornea.
You know what I mean? Because like again and Gatto bigger puncher like,
but like he just doesn't have the skillset that DC has and seeing that, like,
you remember him talking about that in the post fight,
like that was something they saw and to,
to know that that's there and find that opportunity to make that opportunity
happen. You know? That's um, that's high level stuff, man.
That's what the best guys do. I'm, I heard the DC looks fantastic and camp,
I heard it look so good, but I'm really interested in to see what are motivated,
hungry, you know, out for revenge. Steeper can do.
And like he, he knows to take that away. Yeah. You know what I mean?
Um, his DC, he, he kinda got into it.
He explained exactly what they saw and how they figured to use that against him.
So like Steve pay is also, like you said,
he's the most decorated every way champion. He's the most successful. Um,
that's success didn't come from like, not only his skill set,
but also his mentality. So he has to go back into the gym, break that down,
take that out of his game, you know, make that not a, not a thing.
And also now he knows that, that it's, the title's everything.
You lose the title. People don't even talk about you. Yeah.
They stop talking about them. Yeah. You know, I felt a Blige,
I felt like I had an obligation to talk about Steepbank. I'm like,
no one's talking about them. Like,
how are you not talking about the most successful heavyweight champion of all
time? Yeah.
The guy who I understand him having to have one fight before yet in rematch or
he could, he could have legitimately just got the rematch because of the,
of his resume as champion, you know? Um, I don't know. I, I,
I don't like that part of fighting where you only as good as your last fight.
Yeah. No, I don't like it either. I don't, I don't,
I just feel like I get the business aspect of it. I get that.
But I feel like we're a fighter like that. You gotta give him a rematch,
have to deserves it.
He's earned it and oh look a legit champion. The Guy,
he wants a rematch,
set it up. So a quick question where that's concerned, when you say that,
right. Um, Woodley like of course, like you had GSP, you had Matt Hughes,
they had long title runs also, but, um, the fight with Kamala,
Kamala was so dominant in that,
like what does Woodley need to do to get a rematch?
That's an interesting question cause it's a different thing, right? Yep.
I guess it's a different thing, but is it really, I mean, is it real?
Is it really different to dominate a guard than to hit him with one punch?
I mean kind of is, but it's also,
you're dealing with a guy who was like a long time champion who dominated the
division. A guy who, you know,
just blew Darren tills,
title shot hopes up in the smithereens, you know, that was,
that was the big one. Right?
Like the Darren till one because that one was confusing to me. I'm like,
how are the, how is he the betting favorite? I don't understand it. I get it.
He beat cowboy and I guess he dropped Wonderboy, but this is tiring.
Woodley's a guy whose battle tested man,
he's been in there with everybody that I'd felt that was the one of the weirder
believing the hype things in terms of like the bookmakers and it worked out well
for it for Taco or fans that you know, new. Yeah.
But yeah, Dom Kamara was so dominant.
And then you've got Colby Covington who still has the, the, you know,
claim to the interim. They took it away from them, but he's fighting Robbie.
So that's a fight as a fight.
I'm interested in because like we all used to train together. You know,
there was when, when, when Robbie was getting ready for Johnny Hendricks,
remember call me, he's a wrestler and he's a southpaw, you know. Um,
it was years ago and Colby has grown a lot since then,
but I mean those guys spent a lot of time on the mat together a couple of years
ago. You know, how do those training sessions go? I can't tell you that. Yes,
you can if you don't even work for the organization anymore. Yeah. But,
but like one of them is acquaintances. Like none of those,
a good friend blink twice if Robbie fucked him up
and stair cap. I like, you know what I like about it?
Robbie looked physically fantastic in his last fight and I know he lost to Ben
her. It was a crazy controversial situation. I don't know, man.
I went over it with herb dean.
We watched the fight again when herb was in here and I kind of believe him.
I kind of go the way his arm just dropped like that. I'm like,
that seems like he was out. I believe that her, um, spelled, he was out.
I don't think Robbie was out. I think he was out for a second think so, yeah,
I think he was out for a second. And I think when herb came over then Ben let,
let the show to watch that again in slow motion.
But like you don't come back from a chill instantly. Well you do.
If he was letting the choke up while you were fighting. So if,
if Herb's coming over and he thinks Robbie's out and he starts to let up and
then the blood rushed to the brain and then herb stops the fight and he lets it
go and then he's like, nothing
happened. It depends on how long you've been out.
If you're out for only a second, it depends. Depends on how tight the choke is.
He's the blood kind of getting in there and then not kitten in there.
I'm gonna leave it alone. Cause now we're getting in a conjecture. I can't,
yeah, we just point to point now. Yeah, it was disappointing.
But also if he just put him to sleep, that would have been definitive.
But it was just, it was so confusing.
We thought he was out and then he wasn't out and we were like, what?
And then we, the most people thought they had to run it back. Most people. Yeah,
I thought so too. Yeah. I'm surprised they're not,
but I that I'm down for him in Mazda. Yes.
I liked that fight. Yes.
I liked that fight a lot because Mazda doll can wrestle Mazda Dog Russell,
and he's super crafty and he's mean as fuck.
He's a mean man. You know, I'm, I'm not going to lie, man.
I'm going to tell you of all the people I've trained with,
I think overall when you put the entirety of the,
of mixed martial arts to his together,
Mazda might be the best real like he like his boxing is some of the best in the
sport of mixed martial arts. He, he's not a kickboxer,
but he's confident and comfortable with all the kicks. Wrestling.
His wrestling is way beyond a guy who never wrestled. Like, you know, it's,
it's like he's like division one level, you know, at the very least.
And then his Jujitsu people sleep on his Jujitsu man.
Mazda doll is legit on the ground. Um,
the first day I went into American Tahltan,
we had fought each other before and I figured now this guy's horrible on the
ground. We just go. But like, I was like, I was surprised.
And this was like 12 years ago, 10 years ago, you know, and he, and he's, he's,
he's Day in, day out, he's a worker. Like he's constantly working on his craft.
He's constantly working to get better. Um, Ben asked great, and you know,
he's got the ground, he's, you know, he's got the wrestling. Um, but, but miles,
when I was defense of wrestling is he is asking him to be able to, you know,
mall him like he'd just done to everybody else and he's gotta close that
distance. He's got to close that. I mean, and the, on the feet,
Mazda dollar has a giant advantage. Just giant footwork, great hands,
but ask, has this crazy way of getting ahold of people. Even Robbie,
even after Robbie was blasting his brains into another dimension,
he still got up and was grabbing Robbie.
It's like he has this ability to grab people and hold on to people.
Like if you watch this,
the Douglas Lema fight or the Korskoff fight and Bellatore like teases Christ.
Like he bragged all his people. It's weird. And he holds, yeah,
he's hard to get away from it very hard. He got me from,
I remember when I first met Ben, he, um, I watched, he went to this tournament.
He used to do tournament's and in college just to get more pins so you could
have like the pin record. So he got the pin record for,
I'm from Missouri for the University of Missouri. Um, he used to,
but he would also, with other high level wrestlers,
he would just like let people take them down. Oh. I let people in on his
legs so that he can get into these scrambles with that funk stuff that he does.
Yeah. I really, as Dean Thomas, one time, he's wrestling on that same trip.
He's wrestling with Dean and then he just stops everything. He's like,
do you not a sprawl like, like,
like Dean and didn't even know what a sprawl was cause his wrestling is so good.
He just touch, he was touching us and we were fallen over.
I mean mom is the wrestling. Is that good?
Well that makes it even more impressive with Jordan Burroughs to do them.
When Jordan Burroughs in him had that wrestling match,
like there's levels and he said it afterwards, he put it on Instagram.
There's levels to this and there is,
cause he just ran him over right through him.
Power doubles and everything crazy. Just when you think about that,
a guy who's the elite of the elite in wrestling is so much better than the elite
of the elite in wrestling and MMA. Yeah. It is so much better.
But would he have still been able to do that the same way if Ben was only
wrestling some good questions? It's hard to say because Jordan is so good.
He's so dominant.
It's hard to say if you're talking about what two time Olympic champion. Yeah.
And he's unbelievably explosive to any work that you've ever seen. His workouts,
all ply drills, explosive drills,
and he's just all about closing that distance with just ferocious energy.
Boom. That dude crosses that distance like is not even there. God Damn,
he's good. Teleports I was hoping he was going to get into MMA,
but it doesn't seem like he wants to know. I, um, I honestly,
when he was still in school, so one of my buddies, Lynn oding,
he was reaching out. This is how I met Tyron. He's reaching out to, to,
to division one wrestlers for me to help me with my wrestling after the Joe
Stevenson fight. Cause I was like, I can wrestle. Right.
And I'm Jordan Burroughs was one of the guys that he reached out to and he was
just not interested in MMA at that point. Even when he was like,
I'm going to the Olympics, um, I'm gonna Wrestle. He had no interest.
I don't know where that stands now because the sport is bigger,
there's more money in it, but he's still having so much success wrestling.
Right. And who knows how much time, if any, he's putting into striking.
Yeah, but like that IQ of his,
as far as wrestling that that athleticism, you know, he's a hard worker.
Oh yeah. It will apply if he dedicated himself to it. But if he hasn't at all,
he's so far behind the eight ball. Like if he jumps in now with zero striking,
you know,
like how long would it take before he gets to a comfortable level of striking
where he can hang in there. You know,
like remember Kamara Kamara when he first started fighting was really just a
wrestling. Yeah.
But then you really saw on the tire and fight when he almost stopped hiring on
the feet. He's, his striking is legit now. His fight with
Maria Murrayas. Yeah, surgery on rice.
That was where I started to recognize his strikings improving and you could see
it if you watch his fights from men,
you can see it each time a fast improvement in his striking.
But what I like about that is his wrestling didn't really feed.
His wrestling still stayed sharp and that's, that's where I like, I'm like,
how do you do that? Because there's only so much hours in a day. Well,
it's also crazy with him. He can't run. His knees are so fucked up.
I didn't know that he talked to, he doesn't even care to talk.
He doesn't mind talking about it. He's like, Joe, my knees were so fucked up.
I'd have to walk on the grass because I couldn't walk on the concrete because it
hurt too much. How do you fight at that level?
I give you can't run. I don't understand. Well, he just does like Airdyne bike,
but I mean, how do you even,
how do they even work inside the octagon if you can't run on tough?
Just tough. Unbelievable mental toughness. I mean,
I think he gets in there and just forces body to do whatever he wanted to do.
Did you ask him if he feels any pain when he's,
when he fighting's in all the time. Whenever you never see it. Well, you know,
you had a broken foot in that fight. Yeah. That's the kind of,
there's like a mindset that some people have the champion mindset with the,
all that stuff means nothing.
And he had hernias and he had hernia surgery after the fight. I mean,
what the fuck man, that's, yeah, that's, that's some different,
that's some different shit, bro. Says there's levels,
there's levels to the mental game to this.
Like some guys can just push through everything and some guys will find a reason
why they have to get out. Yeah. You know? Yeah.
There's that being in that moment and I'm like, now, now means everything.
There is no tomorrow. You know? It's like, I like to, I, I,
I try to keep that mentality also in some of the things that I try to do now
because like, there's like, I'm this kid from The Bahamas, you know,
there's no reason that somebody in Japan should know my name,
but because of mixed martial arts, because of my dedication to the sport,
because I wanted to be something in that that happened. So it's like,
um, you just have to have that mentality of if I'm on a boat out in,
if I'm in The Bahamas, I'm on a boat and my boat sinks and I'm out in the,
in the middle, I'm 20 miles from land. Like if I don't get the land,
it's not because I failed. That means not because I quit. It's because I failed.
You know, so like that, that mentality. That's how I look at guys like that.
Guys, we just have no quit in them.
I feel like your rye is like favors like that.
You know the Mike Brown for perfect example,
he broke both his hands and was still throwing elbows, kicks,
trying to take him down, doing everything he could to broken hands.
Tony Ferguson, Tony Ferguson's a nano, an animal like that.
He's the scariest guy. One 55. Martin my word, I agree in my world,
cause you don't get tired. The cowboy fight freak me out.
He cowboy looked like Tony had bricks in his gloves. Yeah,
his face was all busted up. Tony didn't look like he had a scratch on him.
And Tony wasn't even tired. Tony posted a meme,
I feel like a couple of days ago he showed like his last seven,
they're all fucked up, but they all fell off a train and yeah, it's crazy man.
He has insane power man. It's like,
it's a weird thing cause Tony does stuff to and does,
he doesn't get tired.
He doesn't get to eat. Like he's legit. Crazy. Yes. Like he does it.
Like,
I don't know if he feels pain that kind of crazy [inaudible] you know what I
mean? Like he will do things in there that I remember when we fought,
I'm South Pole, he's Orthodox, right?
He throws that inside kick and I'm turning my leg over to check it and I'm like,
it was never at my knee. He was throwing that at my shin.
Like if you're throwing that calf kick with that open stance,
you're throwing it out the shin. Right. You know what I mean?
So like I checked it and um, I was like, I was about to check.
And then we bank Shin Duchen like the middle of the shins in the middle of his
shin. And I remember thinking myself, why the fuck would you do that?
Now we're both hurting. Like I seriously hated that feeling, but he did.
Like there was no reaction on his face. There was nothing.
He was just like still on just onto the next thing.
And I feel like I'm glad I fought it men, cause I look at him now,
he's like psychotic.
Yeah. Yeah. Look at the 21st, his last seven opponents,
Jesus Christ, he's got all bloody methods. Even like his,
the what? The things he posts. Like you get an insight to how crazy his mind is.
Like, did you see his posts, his press conference after, um,
after um, Sergio, uh, after Anthony Pettis? No. Yeah, he was talking,
he's talking about how was going to be a doctor. He said, we,
I think he said something like, he said, what did he say? He said, um, he said,
um, oh you say you know what they call me cause he, I, he's like, yeah, he's,
he's GQ guy. He's talking about Anthony. He's, I use a GQ Guy,
but you know what they call me. They call me the GQ killer.
You know what that is so awesome nickname.
Okay.
I would like to see what his conditioning workout is cause Eddie goes with him
up to big bear, you know any, he trains with him and he says, yeah,
Sam never seen anything like it. He said,
everybody else in the camp can't keep up with them. Who works out. He goes,
I've never seen anybody have this kind of dedication and gas tank.
He said he works out a legitimate six hours a day. He says he's running hills,
they do these hill sprints and he said he laps everybody.
He goes all the way to the top before they do goes down and then beats them on
the way up. Said it just doesn't get tired. Yeah, I don't understand.
What is someone doing when their,
their cardio is so much better than everybody else's cause the cowboy fight.
I'm telling you man, I watched him from the moment they,
they stopped the fight after the second round.
I'm watching him and he goes back to his corner. Cowboys face is a mess.
He's just beating the shit out of cowboy. He goes back to his corner.
His stomach isn't even heaving. Yeah, he's not breathing heavy.
I'm not gonna lie to you as I don't want to see this fight cause I like both
those guys. But as a fight fan,
I wanna see this fight and that is him and Dustin.
Oh Him and Dustin would be insane cause like that.
Those are two guys who don't know how to quit. Well if Dustin beats could be,
that's the fight. And if Dustin doesn't be, could
be Tony and could be EBS. The fight. Yeah, they'll fight eventually, I'm sure.
Yeah. I mean that, that is a crazy ass fine.
But the thing is like Tony's pace is so disturbing.
It's so disturbing because I watched him fight guys and I'm like,
how do you keep up with that? Like nobody keeps up with it.
Like you've got to crack him. You got to catch on. Like Anthony caught him,
but he broke his hand. But pet has had him hurt and he and Lando had them hurt.
Lando Vanatta cracked. I've had him hurt. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Bled like knows how to survive though. Yeah, exactly.
And also it's weird because he doesn't survive like most people do.
He doesn't tie you up and try to get shy. We collect as itself.
Like he's just still fights. Yeah. And he like, he instead like scramble.
You heard him, he puts it on you. He's like, okay, I need a break.
Meaning I'm coming after you now you're going to have to stop me from killing
you so then I can take a break. Yeah. I've just,
I'm always stunned at his, his pace and his cardio. It's amazing. I really look,
I just want to know is this scientifically planned?
Like are they monitoring his heart rate or is this just psychotic?
I guess it's scientific or is it psychotic? I think it's the latter.
I think it might be. I like Tony Ferguson. If,
if this was a scary movie, Tony Ferguson would be that guy. He's El Kukui. Yeah.
He's the Boogie man they need. They need the, they need to make a movie out.
Like somebody needs to do some kind of like, I dunno,
Mashup of his fights that make him seem like, like the Jason,
the guy that just never goes away.
And as soon as you turn around and he's ready to kill you,
will you just think about Luke Thomas posted some tweet where the last time Tony
Ferguson one like who was champion and what was going on in the world.
It's like 2013 was the last time he lost and he lost to Michael Johnson. Yeah.
Also beat Dustin. Yeah. Yeah. That was Dustin's last loss as well.
That much more recent though. Yeah, much more recent. I was,
that was here in la. Was it the form? What's up? Yeah. Um,
but that fight also where Dustin's concerned now, like you,
we propped up Tony's,
I gotta get Dustin some props because like that's the thing about,
about mixed martial arts. First of all, there's not a lot of guys who,
who have some success success and then they get stopped.
Then success is success. And then they get stuck and success is success.
Then they get stopped. And then since that like, but every time he got stopped,
every time he lost, he, he made adjustments, made improvements and got better.
Sure. And that was, that was the last one.
And then he had the debacle with Eddie with a disqualification. And, um,
the, the knock on him going into that was, you know, when he hurts somebody,
he doesn't necessarily not finish. He gets too aggressive. You know, Eagle,
he goes crazy. Um, that fight. Then he gets it,
he gets gate where it's like if you hurt him and you go crazy,
you're putting yourself at risk.
So that was the perfect fight to demonstrate that he learned the lesson and he
did.
Yeah. You know, so like I don't know where,
I don't know really what the knock on him is.
Now I remember this is something that, um, I,
I didn't want to say this to him cause he doesn't watch a lot of, um,
his opponents and their, their, their press stuff.
But I remember a long time ago DC had ted could be on the Fox desk and he's
talking to him, he's asking about opponents. He's like,
what do you think of this guy? What do you think of this guy? And he said,
just give me one word answers. And he said, Dustin, poor ea. And he goes,
easy fight. Whoa. And um, I like, I'm like,
yeah, I don't, I go on to see this fight now. You know,
a few things. Then after the hallway fight though,
that was an eye opener for a lot of folks. Yeah.
But Holloway fought Dustin the way Holloway would,
the way Dustin would look the best he stood in front of him.
Holloway doesn't have the same knockout power that Dustin has.
Dustin has like real legit one punch power. Max Beats you up. Yeah,
he just beats it, puts a pace on you, beat your ass and takes you,
takes you out. But also,
I don't think Max has the same kind of power at one 55 he just,
at one 45 he's just so much bigger than everybody. And one 55 he's their size.
And Dustin's a big 55 or, yeah,
I, Dustin is a big 55 I do,
I can't say I agree about the power only because does, yeah,
Dustin's been knocked out but he does have a chin. You know he can take it.
No, but I'm, and I'm not saying he doesn't know. I know you're not know.
This has never knocked anybody out with one shot.
He beats guys up and takes them apart. Yeah, no, you're right. You're right.
Dustin's capable of flatline in yeah. Yeah.
He can flatline people with one shot. Yeah.
You don't really see that that much with Max Max. It's t he just,
he sharp is super sharp,
super high fight IQ and just makes you fight wars with him.
But he was fighting a war with a guy who had higher caliber weapons.
That's what it seemed like in that fight. And Dustin just fought real smart,
great boxing and capitalize on these openings and really stung Matt and w Max in
a way that we haven't seen before. And good footwork too. If you remember,
Max was, Max was using his full work early in that fight.
But everywhere he went, Dustin was there too, you know? Yeah,
it's, there are some times it's not loudly.
Maybe not even a conscious decision where it's like, well it doesn't matter.
Like wherever I go, he's going to be there anyway,
so then this is what we're doing. Right. You know,
I'm not just going to keep running around now. You know? So he might've,
he might've made Max decide to stay in front of him like he did towards this was
the second and third. Yeah.
The differences with Khabib obviously is the grappling. Yeah, that's true.
Could be bread and butter. He's so fucking terrifying. The good,
when he clenches you, it's like you see these guys,
they have this look on their face like what is this? This is a new experience.
This is a different kind of grappling and IOM mobilizes people. Yeah.
Like he gets you in positions that like you are literally, you can't go laugh.
You can't go right. You know,
he's got that wrist wrap on the backside and a half guard on the front side so
you can't turn turn to your right. But you also can't turn to your left.
It's like, and he, he straps you down man. Like,
how do you like, that's what I hope Dustin works on right now.
Like just sealing off,
not allowing him to be able to get those under hooks on the ground,
not allowing, could be able to get around his body and just,
just get back through his feet if he gets taken down. And I mean you,
we saw some of that. We know that could be, he was not the greatest Stryker,
you know, um, we saw, um, I like winter, do some,
do some damage on the feet in I think in third or fourth round of that flight
definitely showed where it could be. If he has any vulnerability,
it's going to be in the striking. But he didn't really hurt him.
Never heard him once. And the only person that Ding them is Michael.
Michael Johnson dinged him once. Yeah.
But he recovered from that quickly and beat the shit out of Michael.
I also in the ground,
I also think Dustin is more of a predator.
Like he's like, I think I like went is good on his feet. He's, he's,
he's boxing solid. He hits hard.
But I think just Dustin's boxing IQ, like if he hurts you,
especially now, I think if he hurts you,
he smarter about being able to finish on what the power that he carries. He, he,
he's more selective with his weapons, you know, so like that.
That's definitely a big option. If he,
if he can show that he can hurt it can be standing then he ha he has a very good
shot of stopping him there. But what does that mean to stop? Could be like,
you know what I mean? Like is it possible? I think,
but you know what I think you have to cause like how do you beat that wrestling
over 25 minutes.
How do you keep them from taking you down over and over and over again?
Just getting back ups not good enough. Yeah.
Cause it's going to keep taking you down. That's a real good point.
Cause he's been able to do that to every single person who's far inside the
octagon. I mean, even when Connor stopped a little bit of it early on,
I mean it's just, it was a matter of time and that's, that's,
that's that whole Gregor thing, man. I want like,
I hope Greg is watching this and he's like, man, I should do that.
I should do that. Cause Eve Eve's calling me out is eve in, um, I mean, um,
it's dusted rather in Florida. Yeah. He just, he just,
so I was in Texas last week. I went up to, I drove down to, um, to New Orleans,
New Orleans to Lafayette Youngsville to, um, to talk to him, to,
to record that podcast. We trained some, um, he made me his, I am,
I'm like, I'm like two hours. I'm like an hour away. And he's like, all right,
you're running practice. And I'm like, I'm fat. I don't know what to do.
I haven't trained like weeks. But, um, he came in and he did that and then, um,
and then he was, he was leaving for Florida that Friday.
So He's been there for about a week now, almost a week now. And the fight is,
what's the date
of the fight? The fight is September 7th Abu Dhabi Tonto.
You're not going to that note. So if, if you do,
if you do a fight companion,
I love to come in for that because if I could [inaudible] because it does cause
just as my boy, man, I want to find out if I'm even in town,
I might be on the road. You're going to be an AC very soon, huh?
I was just there. Oh, okay. That's what it was there this past weekend. Okay.
Oh yeah, no, I'm home. If I, if I'm still home. Um,
as of right now, I'm home, but if I'm still home, we have a fight companion.
You're in Fella. All right. That'll be fun. I'm down to be there.
Especially if I don't go to Obadiah. I would love to be there for that.
But that's how Abu Dhabi, there'll be interesting to, you know him so well,
you know, to get your insight on that. He's the only,
he's the only guy rapping thug Jitsu right now. That's right. I love,
I love when like, he's like,
I'm telling Bruce to make bog me down as a tuck Jitsu fighter.
Like he came up under Tim Krader who's, that's right. You know crazy Tim crazy.
Tim Man.
I remember Tim from the John Jock Machado days like way back in the day.
All right. I saw it first saw crazy Tim. I never got to train with him,
but he came down in like 98 somewhere around there.
Yeah, 98 ish. He started when Tim started trading with me, I was coaching him.
We went to some fights in Boston.
I'm sitting next to the commission and Tim's fighting this guy and he wants,
he's working on a standard with me and they're trading and the guy takes him
down and when the guy takes him down,
I looked at the commissioner and I grabbed like all this stuff and I'm like,
well that's the end of that. I started putting everything in the bucket
and then the commitment, like, I don't know, before I even got my head up,
like Tim tapped him and the, the commissioner was like,
you call that one didn't you? There's some shit that you just know, right.
Especially at a certain level of fights. There's some shit that you just know.
Yeah, that's what I'm,
one of the more interesting things about high level fights and high level
fighters is you don't know anymore. No. It's so like,
because now everybody,
everybody knows the same thing unless you have that checkmate card.
Like Francis, like no disrespected junior.
But I did not think that that fight was gonna get out of the first round.
I had a feeling it was going to go that way and that's what I said to all my
friends. I said if I had to bet my money, anything could happen.
It's crazy sport. But if I had to bet my money,
I bet the house on the big fella. Yeah. Cause he just does shit to people.
Yeah. No. Like I said with that guy, man, those, those only takes one guys.
They're, they're scary. Like, um,
and junior style wasn't necessarily in style too to avoid encounter that,
you know what I mean? Like that, that for me,
like the Jeremy Stevens fight was like that. Jeremy Stevens is those one.
He's that, that, that one punch kind of thing. And you'd just have to,
you have to make sure that they miss and just pick your shots. And me,
it was fortunate
that like I had him, I caught him running into something too. Right. I'm not,
I do have one punch Powell, but I don't pack power like Dustin does, you know?
Um, I'm, I would say my power is more if we're talking about the best today.
Yeah. More about precision, more closer to like Max's in the sense of like,
I w I would pick you apart,
but like all the knockouts they came from like volume or catching you slipping
and catching you coming in or something like that, you know? And um, but like,
so I don't know who's at heavyweight who fights like that. No, bunny.
You'd have to get a Rico Verhoeven.
You'd have to get someone who's like a worldclass Stryker who Rico's had some
MMA fights and he's, you know,
he's still the glory heavyweight champion and he's also a big giant dude.
But then again, man, he's been fighting with those big gloves and you know,
he's been stopped before. Could he handle it? I mean,
if he stands in front of Francis, could he handle it? Yeah.
I don't think any human handles it. Yeah.
That you gotta get a guy like Steve Pei that just knows how to get the fuck
outta there.
I think. I think Francis could knock on an elephant.
He probably could. I'm serious. At least the baby elephant. Yeah,
a little elephant that's fucked up though. Hit even thinking about that as fuck.
Yeah, I don't think there's anybody he can't knock out,
which is really interesting. If he decided to go to boxing,
he's one of those guys where you go. If he really decided to go to boxing,
who hits harder? Hammer Bono. Deontay hit
[inaudible] Deontay hits. So God damn hard.
It's hard to tell because he's Deontay has fought the cream of the crop in
boxing and he's knocked out 39 dudes.
He's 40 and what is he like 40 and one 40 and 39 knock.
Well, how's he 40 you know, he's the Tyson period. Five was a draw.
Oh, 40 oh 40 oh and one. Yeah. And 39 knockouts.
Stubborn was the only one.
The first fight where it went the distance and then he nuked them in the second
fight. Yeah. The first time they fought went to a d I believe that's the case.
Is that who did, who was he? Who did he have a decision with?
Does it say there? You can look in his Wikipedia. That's um,
he hits harder than anybody I've ever seen in the heavyweight division in this
modern era outside of Tyson. I feel like I should call him CTE.
[inaudible] for real.
You remember they did that study on the NFL bodies and they did like 111 bodies
and 110 of them and CTE. Yeah. 39 out of 40. Yeah.
He's giving people some real problems. Still
remains the Vern first fight against him.
Stubborn was the only one that went to distance.
Everybody else gets nuked and he hits guys. They just go flying, you know,
like the fact that Tyson fury got up after the 12th round, like Jesus Christ.
Yeah. That, that, that was crazy. Yeah.
I was like Gypsy kinks of crazy like, yeah, Buddha, look,
he had like a extra chicken bone in his fucking shorts because you see like,
like I don't know,
me I watch, I,
I notice those things like when we were watching that they would sage and an n
and cosmo right when sage went down. Um, and then after cosmo hit him,
like his body like didn't give up. Like they get shut off on him,
but like he was trying to get up. Yeah. Like he was getting up to fight back.
Right. Yeah. Cause if you're, if you're not getting up the fight back,
you're covering up. Right. Right. But he's trying to get up. Um,
same thing where we're Tyson fury goes down the referees in his face and he's
counting the mountain. You see his head, you see his head go
right. And he just gets up just like, fuck it was over. I thought it was over.
I did too. I was watching it at home. I was celebrating. Yeah. I was like,
I want a mix of money. I was watching it at home and my thought was, God damn,
he knocked him out in the 12th round.
How the fuck does that guy carry that power like that the 12th and that Tyson's
backup and then he wins the rest of the round. That was was even crazy.
Deontay bombs on them.
He hits him with some hard shots and then Tyson comes back and dings him and you
see he catches him. Yeah, he did. He wobbled him first. Yeah.
And like this is unbelievable. What a fight that, that,
that was probably the best heavyweight boxing fight I've seen.
I can't remember this. Tyson furious. Let's put it this way.
He hits four times harder than Vitali.
Klitschko he hits five times harder than Vladimir Klitschko.
He hits six times harder than Anthony Joshua.
And he hits eight times harder than Tyson fury. Well, who said that?
Richard Towers. Oh, okay. He's a sparring partner for him. Oh,
I thought it was Tyson furious coat. Yeah. Hmm.
Well that's probably accurate. It says it's Deontay wilder,
a stronger punch that a prime George Foreman.
The thing about Deontae is he knocks everyone out.
[inaudible] is not winning any decisions except one.
I mean there's nobody like that. You even go back to Tyson Tyson when he fought.
I mean he fought a lot of dudes that went to a decision and he beat their asses,
but they went to decision. I honestly,
I wouldn't mind Tyson getting into his camp and just even just kind of mentoring
him a bit like Mike Tyson. Um,
I feel like somebody like that would really help a guy like deal.
I mean he's not like he needs a lot of help. Right.
But like somebody like Mike Tyson being, being, being around,
just having him to like call on, talk to,
sometimes Tyson doesn't really want to have anything to do with boxing anymore
though it seems. And maybe, maybe not even in the gym.
Maybe just somebody to talk to once in awhile, just for maybe some strategy,
maybe even about strategy sometimes. You know, cause I feel, I don't know the,
I forget exactly what it was,
but there was a moment when I was watching Deontay wilder and then there was
something, I think when Mike was in here,
something he was talking about that up, I was just like,
man, those two should get connected. [inaudible] interesting. I was,
I was a long time ago and I was living in Texas.
Well I got a phone call at like 2:00 AM and my one's mind minding my buddies,
my buddy Lynn Odie. And I was like, um, I don't want to,
I don't want to answer that man. I'm trying to sleeping on the bed and my wife,
I'm sleeping on these calls and then the next morning I listen to my voicemail
and he's like, hey, if he, if he, you get this, call me back. I'm like,
he was at a club and he's like,
somebody who wants to talk to you and he has a phone. He's like, even with,
even with
[inaudible] cause I'm so busy, God, man,
I missed a phone call from Mike Tyson. He ran into him in a club or something.
I was like, Mike Tyson knows my name dude. I met him at the,
at the UFC and he's like, Yo, that we got
[inaudible]. I mean, he was in the weed back then, but it was like,
that's what he said goes. He goes, I like you, man. You're funny. I'm like,
thank you. So glad you like
having them in here was so surreal because when I was a kid,
he was the fucking man. I mean, he was the, you would go to pee,
you'd pay to see his fights, just to watch him fuck somebody up.
It wasn't a fight. It was an execution. You would watch him execute guys.
He was the man. He was mad. He changed every way.
Boxing people don't realize that heavyweight boxing in the early eighties was
dead. Nobody cared because Larry Holmes, after he beat Muhammad Ali,
everybody was sad. It was like a sad thing.
Like those are changing in the guard.
Larry Holmes beat the shit out of Muhammad Ali and Larry Holmes never got his
due. He never got his dude. He was so good, man. Larry was so good.
He had one of the best jobs of all time. He was so good,
but people were still upset at him because he fucked up Muhammad Ali. He came,
he was the champ after the greatest, you know,
and not mama only wasn't just the greatest as to,
in terms of like the greatest fighter.
He was a cultural icon. He meant something to people. It was something,
I mean,
everyone knew the guy was out for three years because he protested the Vietnam
War. Everybody fucking hated the Vietnam War.
Especially people who went to Vietnam, hated the Vietnam War, and they,
you know, they, they got it man. And he just, he meant a lot. He meant a lot.
So when Larry Holmes came around, it's like, man, Larry just never got his, do.
Never got his do that arm, that era of boxing.
I remember going back watching tape and, and doing that.
And that's the one thing I appreciate about Tyson. You know, like he,
he was a student. Yes,
thank God he knew Jim Jacobs who have that crazy library that he could get all
that. You know,
John Jacobs was the guy who curated like he has every old time fight all of
them.
He would watch sugar Ray Robinson at Jack Dempsey and he's watching like Willie
pep and he not only watching the heavyweights. Yeah, he watched it every,
oh yeah, Harry grabbed, he watch all those guys,
all his old school and weird obscure fighters,
you know guys that most people don't remember anymore.
Yeah. That, that, that era of boxing was very different. Sandy, Sam Blur
and you know, all those guys, he would watch all those guys. Yeah.
That era of boxing before him was terrible.
It's like you had champs like Pinkel and Thomas and Tony tubs and no one cared
about the heavyweight division.
And then he came along and just started blasting people and the like, finally,
I remember I was, I was like seven or eight years old. I met Trevor Berbick,
he's down in The Bahamas for a flight and that says who Tyson took his belt
from. Yeah. Got His first belt from 20 years old. Yeah, that crazy.
2020 now you're the heavyweight champion. Okay, well that was the thing.
Talking to him about it. Like what was that like? And it just,
there's no way he can manage it. No one can manage that.
You're going to go crazy.
I feel like his career and his life would have been very different if custom
didn't when he did. I think so too. Yeah, I think so too. It's a,
it's a tragic story, but it's also like, there's so many lessons in that story.
So for all of us, it's like there's a lot to learn. You know,
that what happened when it got all the way to buster Douglas when it was like,
he thought it felt like you can't lose and he was in this rare state.
Yeah, yeah. The like his life. Like he's,
he's had so many ups and downs and as,
as the heavyweight and like to be somebody that's the heavyweight champion of,
well, somebody was so many eyes on them, you know, the Robin givens,
all that whole, that whole, so in his life, you know, um, I remember they were,
I forget who was it Oprah when they were being interviewed and on the wall,
they were on the show. And he just, he just kind of looked like,
I feel like Mike Tyson and that interview was like those tigers that people walk
with that they drug. Yes. You know what I mean? Yeah. Perfect.
Perfect way to describe it, man. They probably medicated him. Yeah,
cause he did. He did not look,
he just didn't seem like the Mike Tyson who I was a fan of.
Like I didn't dislike him in that moment. I was just like,
what's wrong with him?
Meanwhile, what? Who the fuck? I mean it had to be her idea.
If I was his friend going, why will you go?
Why are you going to talk to Barbara Streisand? Yeah.
But that's Barbara Walters, whoever it was, get the fuck out of here.
Same thing. Barbara Streisand, Barbara Walters to me saying,
can you talking to some Old Lady? You're the fucking heavyweight champion.
The World Kid Outta here with that talk. Yeah. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
This is nonsense. And you're gonna bring your wife. Woo. What are you doing?
What benefit is,
yeah, it is deaf as well. I can't say definitely,
but [inaudible] my assumption is it was Robyn given you matriculated them.
Yeah. She emasculated them in front of the world and you know,
and I think afterwards he realized what happened. He was furious. Yeah.
But it's like that life is unmanageable. He's,
the life that he lived back then was unmanageable.
He was the fucking King of the world.
He was in his twenties he was buckwild just going crazy flatline.
And people everywhere he went,
people throw rose petals at his feet and screaming, cheering
fans. It's unmanageable. You're too young. Imagine me, you know, poor
adopted black kid with no love in your line. No love in your lane until, yeah,
until you're 13 and then you come into all this money because you're the best
fighter in the world. Like there's,
what could he possibly be afraid of then to nothing. Right.
Pet Tigers, bro. Wrestle with them. I mean,
that was the crazy thing.
And him talking about what he found out that he could get a tiger, what?
I could get a tiger.
But he's so humble now. It's so interesting.
And one of the more interesting things that he said that he doesn't train
because he doesn't want to, he doesn't want to fire his ego up. You know?
He's like, I don't like that part of me.
I don't want that part of me to come out again. I don't, I don't want,
it wasn't a video of him. Like I understand he wasn't training,
it wasn't a video of him. I think last year,
just before he came in here and spoke to you where he's hitting the heavy bag.
I think it was a little bit longer ago than that. But yeah,
he was doing it for something and he's still can crack man
powers and last thing, you'll see that scene.
He's doing a movie and there's a scene in a bar. They're there,
they're doing something and he just shows them a combination.
He just punches in the air, no warm up, Lightning Fast Jab,
hook up or cut right hand. It's like, yikes.
It's all still there and 50 years old still fuck you up. And that was,
that was like, he was the heavyweight champion of my childhood.
Mine to Mohammed Ali. He came, you know, but, but again,
Larry Holmes just doesn't get the credit. It's like for whatever reason,
it's just like in the first round when when Tyson fought Larry Holmes,
it made me think like, damn,
what would have been like if Larry was in his fucking prime,
cause when they fought Lara was like 36 or something like that.
Somewhere around there. It was already kind of over for him. Yup.
And Mike was Mike. I mean Mike was black shoes. No socks.
There it is right here. Why y she
if the weave, yeah, I mean he just can't help.
I mean that was like built into his system, you know, Blah Blah Blah.
Fuck head movement. Delhi, he was a,
he was such an interesting guy too because he was only like five.
He's probably like five ten five 11 I think he was like five 10 and a half,
something like that.
But to be a heavyweight and just so low and bobbing and weaving and moving in
and everybody was like, Jesus. Yeah. You see him coming,
I guess heads right in your chest and he's ripping your body and then upper cut
that right hook to the body and then upper cut behind it that he used on.
Everybody used it on Frank Bruno using on everybody. Boom.
Right up the middle. We had talked to him with Francis Francis. Really?
Francis it's harder. Yeah, he, it's harder. I think so. I think,
I think Mike Tyson, it was a way better boxer. Yeah.
But I think if Mike Tyson can hit like Francis does,
just Francis just has to clip you. He just like,
what would he did a jr he just grazed them.
Obviously there are different gloves obviously.
I just think Francis is such a way bigger man. You know,
Mike at his prime was like two oh nine two 15 round. Then I remember on, on,
on punch out. I never beat him and that would be, yeah,
well, you know Deontay uh, when he fought Tyson fury and he's told me only way,
two oh nine, that's what he weighed. He's, how tall is he?
He's like six, six at least. Yeah. It's crazy. It's crazy.
But I still, I mean I wouldn't want to, I want to see Deontay wilder punch that,
that thing that the UFC has, although I have one of those out here. Those, uh,
what is it called again? The puncho meter. The poncho meter.
That's how I found that thing.
I was looking for someone talking about his punching power somewhere.
If there's any gauge of it. Well, things,
I would never let him punch it if I was his trainer. I'm like,
what if you break your hand? You know,
like what if you fuck yourself up trying to just hit something as hard as you
can. I mean, he's the goose that lays the billion dollar egg.
Deontay if he keeps going, right, like where he's at right now,
he has become the motherfucking man. You know,
especially with that last fight with Dominick Brazil,
he sent him into orbit after the Tyson fury fight. You realize like, okay,
this guy's the fucking man, right? You want to see him fight Andy Ruiz.
You want to see him fight Tyson fury again. You want to see him fight Joshua.
Joshua comes back. He's worth so much money now. I be like,
don't be punching things.
So I guess on that it's the Fox thing where they'd test punching,
but I think it's Fox.
It tested punching power and they actually do have a wilder on this and I guess
Andy Ruiz recently just broke it. Really? Yeah. Oh,
but see that those, it's like a game. I don't know how accurate.
Let me see what Andrew always can fucking punch.
Say the snickers too or something.
He's got a mouthful of food and what's he got on something plus and I think
Wilders was at nine 27. Nine 20. Okay. But I'm telling you that don't mean shit.
It's a matter of how you punch it and it just slams up in this state.
Needless sneakers. Is he trying to get a development deal?
A sponsorship with snickers. That's hilarious. I love Andy Ruiz.
He's coming here. We got them. We got them for the end of the month. I'm fuck,
I'm very excited, man. Deaf. I was crazy. Yeah. Anthony,
Joshua like, um, see that punching power record. That shit ain't real.
You got to hit that thing. Like I have out there where you really can tell,
even though you gotta hit perfectly to kind of, you got to have this sweet spot.
You have a different thing.
I have the one that Francis hit the UFC performance institute has were Francis
broke the record for the hardest punch. Yeah.
How many lightweights have you had hit that? None.
The only worst hit it behind besides Frances is a Joe Schilling and you yeah.
And Brian and
fucking around. No dairy. Brian. He's got 11 knockout power.
Yeah. All right. It's three o'clock. Let's wrap this up. Um,
so one more time. Uh, PFL is next.
The 11th Thursday the 11th Thursday the 11th ESPN and ESPN plus.
So ESPN plus, if you don't have it, get it. It's an awesome app if you like.
Fights has got fucking everything, all sorts of old school.
Canelo triple g fights, all sorts of UFC fights. It's a great app.
It's great app.
And then it's on ESPN two for the main card and the plus.
And you've got words and thug just suck thug Jitsu.
MMA, what is your, your Twitter handle? They'll get to master you to master.
That's right. And what is your, is that the same for Instagram to Instagram?
Twitter. Yeah. And you new podcast out.
Sit Up fam fam out today. Right there you are on youtube. Right.
Thank you brother. Thank you so much, man. Eve Edwards, ladies and Gentlemen,
Goodbye.